bon moi je vais commencer par vous dire
que je suis très content d'une chose
alors ça va faire un vainqueur désignant
c'est la moyenne d'âge des joueurs est
très compétent parce que les conférences
dans public que j'ai l'occasion de
donner en france en général et la
moyenne d'âge plus proches de l'âge de
la retraite
derrière pour faire éclater mais voilà
que je regarde surtout les jeunes qui
ont fait l'effort de venir ce soir
j'espère que mon dans les parcs ou
d'avoir croqué cet amphi contrat
bougisme assurément plus relaxant ou une
séance télévision câblée on va leur
parler d'énergie alors que peut-être que
les choses que je vous dire s'en trouve
partie déjà connue il ya un problème
discute d'énergie c'est qu'on a souvent
affaire à un public dont le niveau de
connaissance est devenu très hydrogène
donc je suis désolé par avance si
certains d'entre vous connaissent déjà
des choses que je veux dire
tout ce que je peux espérer c'est que je
voulais 10 ou 20 ans je n'accepte pas
jusqu'à maintenant j'ai commencé par un
truc pour lequel normalement le souvenir
il est plus récente
une partie de l'assistance que pour moi
qui ai tout simplement rappelé que cette
énergie savez si vous demandez à
quelqu'un dans la rue c'est quoi
l'énergie en france en tout cas il va me
répondre je sais ça mc touré gace que
c'est sa facture d'électricité
éventuellement quelques-uns audience et
la naissance c'est parce que les pluies
ça va s'arrêter là bien évidemment
personne ne va vous donner la définition
l'énergie tels qu'un certain nombre
d'entre vous l'ont reprise en cours
c'est à dire que l'énergie c'est par
définition la marque du changement
d'état d'un système c'est à dire la
marque du changement dit autrement dès
qu'il se passe quelque chose
le monde qui vous entoure dès que avant
et après ces différents vous avez de
l'énergie qui est entré en jeu
transformé bond ou utiliser de l'énergie
c'est exactement pareil je reprends la
personne qui pense à sa facture
d'électricité sa facture de gaz
c'est très facile de lui faire
comprendre par exemple on change de
température il ya de l'énergie qui
incarne moi je te dis partout la crue ce
qu'on appelle la consommation d'énergie
comme vous le savez des pagnes
consommation d'une transformation
d'énergie
une partie de la consommation de
l'énergie que nous avons consiste à
modifier une température
c'est vrai dans le processus industriel
c'est vrai dans la nature de nos formes
pierre une partie de l'énergie que nous
utilisons sert à changer de vitesse
autre transformation de l'environnement
alors c'est celle qui par exemple c'est
une voiture qui était immobile ce
désagrément que le thalys c'est arrivé
jusqu'ici alors et que les marchandises
sont livrés dans les magasins ce qui
permettrait accessoirement on utilise de
l'énergie pour changer de forme alors
qu'il s'agisse de temps une chaussette
22 tâches ou qu'il s'agisse d'emboutir
une tôle a là aussi on va déformer
quelque chose et on va utiliser de
l'énergie du reste inversement en sorte
tous les temps a donc fournir de
l'énergie
vous avez de l'énergie qui intervient
par me changer une composition chimique
est la première manifestation de cette
énergie c'est celle qui nous permet
d'exister c'est l'énergie qui est
contenue dans votre alimentation avec
l'alimentation pour la mesure et dong
energy fameuse calories qui vaut mieux
éviter de manger en excès des comptes
approche tout eh eh bien cette énergie
chimique qui permet à notre corps se
mouvoir add également libéré
un certain nombre d'autres processus par
exemple sur une demi de soleil si j'ai
bien compris on fait beaucoup pour que
cette conférence
phyllis travailler si l'on fait la salle
vous avez de l'énergie qui entrent en
jeu dès que vous avez un corps se
déplacer en marchant avec lequel il
interagit alors c'est bon ou ça vous
évite de flotter dans l'air comme
capitaine haddock dans tintin mais sa
victime sur la lune donc vous avez votre
manifestation de ces interactions qui
sont également utiles dans un certain
nombre de dispositifs qu'on utilise vous
avez bien évidemment de l'énergie qui
entrent en jeu dans une compétition
atomique change bien pour ça que les
alchimistes en guyane a relié à leur fin
dans le besoin doit clarifier fallu
beaucoup d'énergie course en france
multiple en oeuvre et enfin vous avez de
l'énergie qui nous intéresse beaucoup à
partir du 1er juillet qui est
l'interaction entre la matière et le
rayonnement qu'à chaque fois que vous
avez d'interaction pour la matière les
prélèvements vous avez d'énergie qui
entrent en jeu vous avez une utilisation
au conflit quotidienne et non plus
paresseuse de cette même énergie qui
four à micro ondes pour tous les gens
qui sont donc d'une manière générale
l'énergie ça n'est rien d'autre que la
transformation du monde qui nous entoure
partant de là les premières choses que
je peux déjà vous expliquer ces énergies
propres
ça n'existe pas vous savez propre cdc
des toilettes dans l'état dans lequel on
l'a prouvé à l'excès d'avoir touché à
rien su utiliser d'énergie si elle a
changé donc l'énergie propre
ça n'existe pas en général les énergies
qu'on appelle propres sont des énergies
qui sont tellement petit en fournitures
que je ne change pas grand chose dans le
monde qui nous entoure donc elle ne vous
emmerde pas beaucoup de talent au
travers de fonds propres si on avait un
moteur diesel et insolent à la surface
de la planète et des excès propres
si vous aviez un micro barrages et un
seul à la surface de la planète et
dwight répond c'est petit si ça devait
un monde en termes de fourniture
électrique comme les raisons du chardon
pas sur l'entreprise atteint donc le
l'énergie propre qui n'existe pas
en ce qui concerne l'énergie c'est
toujours c'est pour ça que c'est depuis
longtemps un domaine dans lequel on
trouve beaucoup d'ingénieurs l'énergie
c'est toujours une affaire d'heures
demandeur faire du chiffre on peut pas
sortir d'un débat sur l'énergie sans
dérapage reconnais dans une approche
mentale de la question c'est très
marrant pour aller boire un verre de
walbach mais il ya peu de chances qu'on
progresse vers une solution de gestion
de l'énergie au baril alors parlons
chiffres et certains d'entre vous ont
peut-être entendu parler justement
claudique le saut en politique ce n'est
pas une invention c'est de tous
on est tous de plus des surhommes de
moutier comment est ce qu'on a fait pour
y arriver à l'enfance par un faux départ
contre le sens physique ça c'est sûr
alors comment est ce qu'on a fait pour
ça
eh bien on a trouvé de l'énergie qui
nous affaiblit un immense et tout ce
qu'elle est c'est toutes les machines
sont utilisées et donc vous allez voir
que la puissance est considérablement
supérieure à celle je vais commencer par
vous en est moins due qu'à pays parce
que ce que d'efforts que je vais vous
faire faire vous à faire chez vous
quelques avantages en france je vais
vous faire voter sur fond blanc quand
vous allez à charbonnier est monté sur
dix blancs déjà fait ça oui tous les
quatre matins a votre avis il vous fait
monter sur mont blanc vous allez
restituer combien énergie mécanique
vous n'êtes pas grave en deuxième
semaine de septembre
je conviens indices en ligne qui leur
colle sans dieu mgr j atomique ont monté
sur le volant un demi kilo watt heure
d'énergie mécanique d'instituer un demi
kilo watt heure démarche ridicule aux
gens sont capables de fournir une
énergie mécanique ridicule des hommes et
des biens le site ouest si vous utilisez
les droits pour fournir du travail sur
une journée à l'origine en fait pas que
vous faites un énorme de troupes ou
planter un arbre que j'ai pris en
exemple c'est un jeu dans lequel les
quais ces cinq mètres cubes de terre de
russie red bull et bien vous allez
restituer le couple au 02 05
kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique donc
un être humain avec sa carcasse il est
capable maximum maximorum de fournir de
l'eau kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique
par jour sauf quelques sportifs
surentraînés qui n'êtes pas capable de
faire ça tous les nouveaux plutôt
capable de faire ça arrange sur deux -
jour sur 3 ce qui veut dire que l'ordre
de grandeur de l'énergie mécanique
maximale qu'un être humain est capable
de fournir sur une année c'est à peu
près 100 kilowatts
retenez un être humain est capable de
fournir 100 kilowatts heures de travail
qui leur doit être pareil sur une année
vous allez voir à présent comment sommes
nous là pour le moment je veux vous
faire un tout petit peu d'économies
admettons que ce travail ne soit fournie
par une personne qui travaille en
occident payés au salaire
tant que celui qui en france est à peu
près vingt mille euros par an avec
charge
j'imagine qu'en belgique on n'est pas
encore au bilan revenant du même ordre
de grandeur est bien un instrument si
cette personne l'utilisant va fournir du
travail mécanique
je vais payer mon kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique quelques centaines à
quelques milliers d'euros quelques
centaines à quelques milliers d'euros
maintenant je vais être impactés pas
social du tout donc je pars dans un pays
que je ne nommerai pas faire travailler
des enfants malades noble projet offrant
enfin exactement 11 000 centimes
même s'il ya un esclave je suis quand
même obligé de l'acheter
kutscher de nourrir une heure de le
préserver des prédateurs et proies des
maladies etc publiquement un peu
d'argent et bien kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique
venant d'un esclave je ne paye pas les
forums tout ce que je paye ici c'est sa
survie va quand même le goûter de
l'ordre de quelques euros à quelques
dizaines d'euros le kilowattheure à côté
de sa hache pour acheter un litre
d'essence donc comme vous le savez le
prix déchaîne les foules dans un vol
d'essence vous avez 10 kilowatts heure
d'énergie thermique vous fait passer ça
dans un moteur conçu par un ingénieur
français sur dix y ont fait mieux de la
4 kilowatts heure d'énergie mécanique
vous allez donc payer un coût marginal
j'espère que le show du matin quelques
dizaines de centimes kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique
dit autrement l'énergie aussi difficile
que nous utilisons aujourd'hui permet
d'obtenir de la transformation du monde
c'est l'affirmation du monde pour mille
à deux mille fois moins cher que le
travail de main payés au smic une fois
que vous êtes et ça je vous ai expliqué
pourquoi vous avez tant des traces dans
cette salle audio
d'avoir transpiré toute la journée à
faire pousser des patates et objets car
vous seriez voire de fatigue en ce
moment et vous seriez au fond de grille
pourquoi est ce que votre pouvoir
d'achat
est ce qu'il est pourquoi est-ce que
nous avons tant dans votre bureau
et bien ça c'est une conséquence
pourquoi l'économie s'est mondialisée
pourquoi vous buviez depuis longtemps
pourquoi etc
tout ça vient de là et ça ça vient du
fait que nous utilisons en quelques
siècles une épargne que la berd
la terre a fait en quelques centaines de
millions d'années les caps au départ m
fm ils s'appellent les combustibles
fossiles
il ya eu un taux départ d'extrêmement
ferme sur le rayonnement solaire qui est
arrivé à la surface de la planète en est
le sens thann millions d'années ça en
fait une petite cagnotte qui s'appelle
le pétrole le gaz et charbon
ramé en quelques siècles et ça nous
permet aujourd'hui d'avoir des
revendications sociales des problèmes
c'est une affaire d'état alors parlons
kilowattheure vous avez sur cette cour
la quantité de kilowattheures exprès de
l'environnement et consommés par
personne alors j'ai pas tellement lourd
ce n'est pas ce que vous savez encore
une fois l'énergie qu'on se bat qu'on
soit en fait c'est plutôt transformé par
personne j'aimerais qu'ils ont cédé
je suis désolé de faire ce petit entend
souvent la visite donc c'est la quantité
des kilowattheures extrait de
l'environnement par personne et par an
depuis un siècle et donc ici nous sommes
dans 1860 dans son indépendance lui qui
tenait à cette époque là un terrien ont
sauvé de leurs 2500 kilowatts heure par
an et c'était essentiellement du bois du
chardon et ça servait essentiellement
affaire d'achat leurs aveux de
métallurgie un peu de trac bateau à roue
et puis vous voyez la quantité de
charbon par personne augmente puis se
stabilise à jamais des crues et elle a
recommencé à augmenter
puis là dessus jusqu'à l'idée de pétrole
puis la suite
garage puis c'était à tous et empilés
les uns sur les autres
alors le charbon mais j'avais des clous
on va le voir après parce que
l'essentiel du charbon sert à produire
de l'électricité et que l'électricité
n'a jamais été cru et les avez ici au
pétrole et d'énergie règne les
transports lorsque vous avez du temps où
je reviendrai tout à l'heure en bleu là
ces nouvelles énergies renouvelables
donc c'est l'éolien le photovoltaïque le
biogaz la géothermie de trois parties et
passionnant les journalistes massés dans
cette courbe présente une inflexion
spectaculaire au moment des chantres et
rognac et je viendrai après sur l'effet
que ça a eu un les chocs pétroliers ont
marqué le tournant dans un tournant dans
l'évolution du monde que je décrirais
entre 1860 et 1980 vous voyez qu'on est
passé de 8 500 kilowatts heure par
personne et par an à environ 20 milles
donc on a un peu de croissance de
l'énergie disponible par personne qui
est à peu près dé tenir 2 5% par an
alors ôté ce pourcentage vous verrez
après le lien direct qui lie avec
l'évolution économique qu'on a connus
sur cette période
et puis de 1980 ça s'est
considérablement tasser et le taux de
croissance est plutôt de l'ordre de 0
15% et en fait si j'enlève le charbon en
chine
il est lui encore la totalité de la
hausse et de charme en chine ailleurs
dans le monde
vers les combats près il n'en reste pas
moins qu'aujourd'hui on est arrivé au
stade où chaque personne sur terre
consomme en moyenne marine
kilowattheures par an c'est à dire
l'équivalent en moyenne annuelle de la
mise à disposition toute la ville de la
puissance musculaire de deschamps
esclaves en occident mais plutôt à 500
on est plutôt à 50 ou 60 mille
kilowattheures consommés par personne et
par an vous et moi nous vivons
exactement comme si on avait chacun 500
esclaves à votre disposition qui
pédalait toute l'année et sur des vélos
pour faire tourner toutes les machines
qui vous permettent de vivre comme une
idée aujourd'hui machine
des sièges sur lequel vous êtes assis et
vêtements que vous portez et le net que
vous portez et plats que vous avez mangé
avec des moyens de transport que vous
avez utilisé chose cette pièce dont fait
la pièce qui ont fait beau logement etc
etc qui ont fait de traduire des
médicaments essentiels tout ça tout ça
cinquante à soixante mille
kilowattheures par an dont qu'ils
reviendraient les pouvoirs d'achat de
l'énergie les droits sociaux de
l'énergie
votre haine de l'énergie le divorce de
l'énergie les études longues de
l'énergie les vacances de l'héberger
tousart de l'énergie vous vous rappelez
à des citoyens athéniens ont en mains
libres en fait c'était poignée de jambes
au milieu d'une armée nice car les pays
occupés voilà bah non c'est exactement
pareil sauf que nos esclaves 7 milliards
d'habitants 1400 milliards d'esclaves
virtuelles qui permettent de 7 milliards
à vivre comme ils vivre encore vous et
des machines ils se nourrissent de
pétrole et de gaz et charbon jeu pas
douter manger pétrole magazine jambes
c'est très exactement comme ça qu'on est
entre amis aux jambes alors je vous
disais que en occident c zéro vous avez
ici la consommation d'énergie par
personne alors à 100 dinars de 65
c'est surtout la période récente qui
m'intéresse donc vous avez ici et c'est
des tonnes d'équivalent pétrole de
kilowattheures et peu importe ce que
vous voyez c'est que ce que je vous
disais ce que vous êtes tout à l'heure
depuis 1981 ça va pas augmenter là ça a
commencé à thiviers je reviendrai après
parce que c'était dur cdm il demeure
donc les jeunes qui sont dans cette
salle vont avoir la chance grossi du
reste de vivre une période inédite qui
peut être à la fois une période
exaltante ruiz période terriblement
dangereuse
peut-être les deux fois qui va être le
renversement d'un système
c'est la fin de la productivité
croissante on va rentrer dans une ère de
productivité décroissance c'est la fin
de la croissance du pib
on va rentrer dans une
stagnation des sessions successives donc
ces quelques rallonges quoi ça doit être
désespérant ordinaire mais en tout cas
c'est une mutation ma mutation on va
alors reprenons un peu notre histoire
voilà comment a évolué non plus par
personne mais au total la consommation
d'énergie donc voilà comment a évolué la
capacité de transformation de l'homme
sur son environnement
d'accord et comme l'énergie qu'on
utilise aujourd'hui l'utiliser de
manière plus efficace qu'il ya un siècle
et demi en fait la capacité de
transformation de l'environnement s'est
même pas cette course et cette courbe
augmenté sur la fin d'un facteur 2 h là
vous comprenez que en parallèle avec
l'augmentation de cette consommation
d'énergie et donc de la transformation
de l'environnement est bien là tout un
taux de tout un tas d'autres sujets
pardon qui se mettent à l'énergie qui
n'existait pas avant parce qu'ils sont
corollaire d'une transformation
croissante des pollutions les
artificialisation des soucis de ceux là
grosso modo l'essentiel des dommages que
l'e-mail environnementaux sont
extrêmement bien corrélé aux invasions
de physique de base à la consommation
d'énergie très bonne corrélation fois
l'énergie ces changements
quand vous changez monde fait des sous
produits indésirables pour vous faites
de la production aidée par leurs trucs
pour nous de répandre
l'essentiel de cette consommation
d'énergie et le fait de combustibles
fossiles
j'y reviendrai alors je vous ai dit ça
fortement changé la situation des chocs
pétroliers vous avez ici la variation de
la commision helmand énergétique
primaire de l'humanité depuis 1965 et
locales attendent 45
mais vous voyez ici la moyenne sur la
période 45 75
donc en gros c'était plus simple pour
cent par an de consommation énergie
de 45 à 75 est ici poste choc pétrolier
la moyenne est plutôt à 2% par an envoyé
près 20 marches d'escalier qui a été
descente est en fait ce truc line tyne
homogène vous avez ici l'évolution de la
consommation énergétique mondiale depuis
65 et de les distribuer en 3e rona les
pays dotés de l'os qu'on a coutume
d'appeler les pays riches mais enfin qui
relativement sont de moins en moins
vous savez la chine cédé 4,5 millions
d'occidentaux au lever 100 millions à
merde il ya 400 millions d'occidentaux
dame en chine donc dire que la chine est
un pays émergent lorsque cet art qu'ils
discutent pour la partie pas il met de
la partie tout à fait les berges de la
chine qui dope agroscope l'europe
donc vous avez ici la consommation des
pays hors ocde donc en gros le
rockabilly que j'appelle moi quelqu'un
d'autre petit l'accord du sud ici les
pays hors ocde orchies est ici la chine
est ce que vous voyez c'est que la
consommation d'énergie globale des pays
ocde elle fait la une très belle courbe
très homogène avec un petit accident en
mais vous voyez que clairement avec des
millésimes négative depuis un certain
temps et simple à fouad et ça commence à
baisser doucement
après alors voilà ici l'évolution de
l'approvisionnement énergétique
d'atteindre les évolutions de taux de
croissance de l'approvisionnement
énergétique primaire des pays de l' ocde
et donc la cote de tendance que vous
avez là dessus de la maison
donc vous voyez que la en vente
et ça date pas d'hier la tendance était
claire 40 sur 45 ans et on rentre
valence et vraisemblablement nonobstant
tout effort à mon avis qu'on pourrait
faire sur le but des ressources utiles
par ailleurs don de sang tout l'effort
pourrait faire sur nucléaire on va
rentrer dans une époque dans laquelle
l'approvisionnement
angers tic au lieu d'exclure allemand
orienté à la hausse il va devenir ce que
tu vraiment je regarde quelle est la
situation aujourd'hui alors voilà tout à
l'heure je vais montrer l'évolution dans
le temps là je le prends la tranche de
saucisson de l'année 2011
ce qu'a d'ailleurs sur man et de l'igs
alors qu'est-ce qu'on a consommé en 2011
dans le monde on a consommé pour un
blues dakar du charbon alors énergie
primaire ont fait d'accord c'est
l'énergie qu'on extrait de
l'environnement or ces d'énergie qu'on
trouve dans l'environnement et ont
extrait dans l'environnement on trouve
les vaches à qui brûlent charbon gaz
pétrole voire on trouve du règlement on
trouve du vent qui souffle on trouve de
l'eau qui tombe contre ou éventuellement
des différences de température entre
l'océan de surface et de ses enfants
font enfin on trouve à la faute tout ce
genre de truc ça s'appelle de l'énergie
primaire alors en 2011 va extraire
environnement l'équivalent de 13
milliards de tonnes de pétrole en
énergie primaire équivalents à ceux ci
parlent du pétrole en compte l'énergie
si vous voulez avoir des kilowattheures
multiplier 13 milliards par 1600 et vous
avez le résultat donc c'était moins le
cas du charbon pour un petit tiers des
personnes perdront cinquième du gaz en
euros 75 à 80% de ce qu on a extrait
c'est donc ces fameux combustible et
souci ça fait du co2 entre sancerre
difficiles et j'avais générait tout à
l'heure cette énergie primaire pour la
fait passer dans un système énergétique
en l'accusant fatals picards en général
on l'a fait passer dans un système
énergétique par exemple au pétrole
raffiné le charbon enlevé dans une
centrale électrique c'est à dire un gros
trou noir et il a dû donner
l'électricité le gaz une jolie fille ont
fait passer tout ça dans un système
énergétique et on en sort d énergie
finale les énergies final c'est celle
que nous fait rentrer dans des machines
ou domestiques ou industrielles alors
exemple de machines domestiques dans
laquelle mourant
original machinal avec l'ange corps ça
consomme d'électricité est une machine
comme son nom l indique
et ça consomme d'électricité de
fréquents la cafetière sur laquelle on
aurait du mal à travailler encore un
autre exemple votre future voiture toute
machine consomme une idée originale et
raffinée l'énergie finale dans la banque
l'énergie qui nerfs parce que entre les
deux il ya des choses que ça faisait
perdre et perdre ses d'énergie que vous
perdez en route au moment de la
conversion et que vous n'arrivez pas à
récupérer
c'est pour l'essentiel les cartes
thermiques dans les centre analytique
dans le rendement moyen des centrales
thermiques d'annoncer un tiers et 85 %
d'électricité dans le monde et fait avec
les centrales thermiques qui a des
centrales ces grosses vouloir appliquer
commencé à faire bouillir de l'eau en
été l'eau sous pression avant de faire
la vapeur que là vous faire tourner une
turbine qui pas l'électricité
j'ai dit électricité l'électricité et
l'énergie finale bien évidemment on
mange pas les cafouillages dans
l'éclairage des idées pour le faire les
choses donc l'électricité et l'eau si
bonne idée que la variable contrairement
à ce qu'affirme le cheikh pdg cette
chaire firme automobile renault qui pose
de temps en temps une voiture électrique
sur lequel est écrit en gros zéro co2
une fois que la voiture est faite il ya
d'électricité fait d'armes
mais sinon d'électricité et tu peux
aussi bonne idée car l'arrière
d'affaires les pays les plus électrifié
vous verrez après c'est possible
les émetteurs de co2 n'a pas de site et
pas spécialement une énergie propre
salle
comment fait-on l'électricité dans le
monde vous avez ici de bâtons qui vous
donne la décomposition de la production
électrique mondiale juste avant que les
chances de trier et il ya quelque chose
à l'échelle est traduit en milliards de
kilowattheures 6 milliards de watts
heure car à votr en 1973 vingt mille en
aujourd'hui on est emprunté à un bilan
plus blanche en la pour mémoire je n'ai
pas les chiffres pour la belgique mais
en france on produit aujourd'hui un peu
plus de 500 térawattheures d'électricité
par an le monde dans son ensemble en
cours seraient six en 1945 monde dans
son ensemble entre ce v6 en 1945 donc
l'électricité c'est une énergie de la
deuxième moitié du xxème siècle pourrait
presque dire ses idées c'est une énergie
c'est à railler fonctionner ces décès
c'est vraiment un truc c'est sans
vraiment un truc récent j'ai eu quelques
sexagénaire dans les gens que je connais
dans le monde de la recherche académique
ils ont grandi dans une ferme dans
lesquelles il y avait pas de chômage
sans faille pas l'électricité
ils ont dix ans plus que moi donc
l'électricité s'est traduit quelque
chose qui est le fait de la deuxième
moitié du 20e siècle
c'est d'arriver du lot dans les villes
et dans les campagnes d'électricité
c'est arrivé très tard en 1973 les trois
quarts de l'électricité effet des
combustibles fossiles
donc en fait brûler des combustibles ça
fait tâche à l'heure on fait un rapport
que touring jambes comme si une hache et
des cadeaux à vous perdez une partie de
l'énergie
d'autre part au challenge argent en deux
sexes les combustibles fossiles ces deux
tiers de l'électricité que nous
produisons sur terre tu es vous voyez
que ce qui a le plus augmenté d'une
barre à l'autre ses chats encore
aujourd'hui quand vous regardez les
centrales en construction dans le monde
c'est le charbon qui arrive en tête
alors en france on l'aimé bien ici dès
qu'il ya un quart de centrales
nucléaires qui est construit par un
quart du pays quelque part dans le monde
c'est un shopping cela je pense
absolument abominable
la chine met en service une tranche à
charbon par semaine avait il dit aux
français s'en foutent royalement donc le
et quand on construit des centrales à
charbon g co2 en 3d pourquoi donc le
chardon est la première des énergies
primaires utilisés pour faire de
l'électricité à passer de gaz qui a le
plus cruel et après et après seulement
vous avez trouvé une augmentation de
l'hydro électricité du nucléaire alors
parlant charbon je prends le point
d'orgue sens voilà à quoi ressemble la
quantité de charlotte ont sauvé sur
terre depuis 1970 71 en l'occurrence
c'est gravé en millions de tonnes
équivalent pétrole bep vous voyez que
l'essentiel va dans l'électricité
l'essentiel du charbon extrait sur terre
va dans la production électrique ce qui
va dans la sidérurgie c'est juste le
petit machin rouge dans le charmant de
valeur ajoutée en termes de quantité de
charbon consommé sur terre c'est juste
un petit machin il est bas en dynamique
c'est pas grave
ici vous avez la répartition arrosage du
pétrole consommé sur terre en 1973 et en
ouais les usages industriels ont diminué
transports a très fortement augmenté que
la matière première de faire du
plastique c'est ça le donne énergétique
a très fortement augmenté et enfin que
autres c'est essentiel en chauffage lui
il a plutôt diminué
prenons garde alors le gars qui sert à
l'étape machin mais il sert quand même
beaucoup au chauffage en jaune et à la
production électrique en bleu et dans
l'industrie issers et saint célerin à
produire de la chaleur
en parlant de la sidérurgie ont
réchauffé les braves et du gaz dans le
fond avait utilisé du gaz pour chauffer
on a aussi alors tout ça encore une fois
c'est pas tellement que nous avons
réussi à nous abreuver de chez sur ses
ventes ans on a événement sur terre des
énergies renouvelables
je vous ai montré tout à l'heure les
nouvelles renouvelables des petits fils
est là machin
or il ya une loi du genre qui marche
très bien dans les médias français qui
est la pagination dans les médias sur
les énergies
nous l'avons inversement proportionnelle
à leur importance réelle j'ai pas si
c'est pareil ici mais en france c'est
une joie et ça me regarde la première
énergie renouvelable dans le monde et de
très loin c'est le bois et les déchets
de bois et les listes de yack etc
alors il se trouve que fuite partie de
cette énergie les jarres plus renouvela
dans un certain nombre d'endroits dans
le monde et en particulier la recherche
de boîtes fait en afrique qui est une
pause vers les déforestations les genres
on a du mal à savoir ce qui a renouvelé
ce ce qui par contre est dans cette
histoire pour le moment les usages
continue à être demain tu le poids ou là
ce qui selon lui la deuxième énergies
renouvelables de très loin une autre est
mince et l'hydroélectricité et quand
vous regardez les capacités en
construction aujourd'hui dans le monde
c'est aussi des très longs à la première
des énergies électriques renault car
moins deux enfants et ensuite et ensuite
seulement vous avez le vent alors
l'avenir en équipage primaire ce qui est
la plus avantageuse des conversions ça
fait moins de 20% les agrocarburants ça
fait un demi pour cent
vous avez aujourd'hui sur terre 60
millions de tonnes équivalent pétrole
d'un conte carburant en face vous avez 4
millions de tonnes de pétrole
donc pour trans pour remplacer à 25% du
pétrole de 2 consommons on consomme déjà
la marque quasiment la moitié du maïs
américain pour faire ça les américains
transforme on est alors une 40% leur
maïs c'est à dire la même quantité que
ce qui va nourrir des animaux est mon
point de vue et d'un scandale absolu
mais vous voyez les ans demandeur open
rails oui les ans demandeur verdun et
enfin le photovoltaïque lui c'est 0 1%
alors imaginons nous
un constructeur de voitures et que les
ventes sur les voitures baissent et vous
vous dis que c'est pas grave de
compenser en écrite bonnet encore
question ces questions pour un champion
en fait c'est quoi les consentent à
composer qu'elle est très appliqué
autres bonnes pour que le chiffre
d'affaires des couronnes ce matin peut
penser que s'ils d'affaires des voitures
car du corps et puis enfin moreschi
éventuellement les gens ont besoin
d'autant de ton d'un blog
donc là c'est pareil de temps en temps
vont ils passer des calculs en disant
oui c'est pas grave que ce soit 0 1 un
jour on s'est regardés en venant de
presque 5 alors cette énergie je voulais
déjà dit deux fois je vais me rappeler
de troisième fois elle a transformé
brouiller la bâloise a permis pour tous
ceux d'entre vous qui sont étudiants
jeunes ingénieurs défi relevé teague 17
vous avez ici ce que je vais vous
montrer maintenant c'est pour la france
les qualitativement ça s'est passé
exactement de la même manière dans tous
les pays occidentaux
vous avez la décomposition de l'emploi
sur les deux guerres de siècle en france
et je lui envoyé aux français ordinaires
mais je pense que d'être ordinaire ce
que pareil il ya deux siècles
il était à l'elysée les deux tiers de la
population arrivait à produire la
nourriture on se nourrir eux plus le
tiers restant qu'ils aient à
l'agriculteur arriver à nourrir une
vermine 100 personnes d'accord vous avez
également on après l'industrie mais qui
à l'époque était le début les petites
piscines avec nous a mis beaucoup
d'artisanat et puis les services et à
l'époque les services est
essentiellement les commerçants et les
emprunts une raison
n'est pas encore le finance triomphante
dans laquelle j'espère que le moins
d'ingénieurs possible de l'ulb est
sécurisé puis arrivent les machines à
l'appartement la crise de lehman
brothers et le patron de patrons
retraités de saint gobain qui disait
partout on va enfin pouvoir récupérer
les arts et les machines alors les
machines au début elles sont industriels
elles sont pas dans les champs mais elle
vous permettre de faire des outils
agricoles de plus en plus performants
donc on perd personne l'état technique
voulait faire des choix et charles
j'sais pas quoi et c'est une cabale de
fiabilité en grande série et ça ça
augmente fortement la productivité du
travail agricole
et puis un jour on se met même à mettre
les machines dans les champs qui
s'appelle détracteurs et à ce moment on
augmente encore plus rapidement la
productivité du travail à l'école quant
au nombre de rentes la productivité du
travail et l'école n'augmente pas
corrélativement les surfaces cultivées
de la superficie d'un pays et l'escale l
on peut couper une partie des forest a
fait le reste pour faire des chambres
enfin ça va beaucoup moins vite que la
productivité du travail
eh bien vous sortez les agriculteurs des
champs mais ça arrive avec des pop ya
des tas d'autres ressources à
françois-henri avec plein d'énergie pour
faire des tapas chain on peut perdre les
objets manufacturés on peut faire des
draps en coton de faire des machines du
reste à faire les grandes photos on peut
faire le plein puisque schilling donc on
comprend toutes les autres sources
sécuritaires on prend l'énergie et où
les gens dans des boîtes à transformer
les ressources et d'énergie en hajek
s'appelle des fusils et puis derrière on
met des services courants 6h17 et donc
vous avez l'emploi dans l'industrie et
dans les services qui augmente arrive
sur pétroliers c'est à dire l'inflexion
sur la quantité d'énergie disponible par
personne que je vous ai monté tout à
l'heure à ce moment arrêt de la hausse
très rapide de la productivité
connectivité continue à monter beaucoup
moins vite moins vite
elle monte plus vite que le fus
industrielle globale et à ce moment là
par de l'emploi dans l'industrie
descendre quand par les services les
gains de productivité sont reculant à
obtenir ça nous empêche pas que dans le
même temps on continue à augmenter les
services
parce que quand vous avez un flux
industriels qui augmente même faiblement
bas derrière voulait mettre un flux de
service qui augmente même faible mais on
peut aussi apparaître à cette époque un
truc qui n'existait pas dans le champ
d'arc avant les chocs pétroliers
nulle part mme sylla ans au fond comment
la crise hrw
vous n'aviez de chômage structurel
significatifs de parts vous pouvez avoir
un petit chômage des idoles comme dans
les valises pleines encore aujourd'hui
en radio pour cent mais vous n'aviez pas
de chômage structurel avec 2 % ça
n'existait pas la british que ce truc là
arrive dans tous les pays occidentaux en
même temps le chômage
le bal des pays occidentaux depuis les
champs pétroliers avance at-il système
et c'est la conséquence directe du fait
que vous n'avez plus assez d'énergie
pour permettre au système de s'organiser
vous n'avez déjà plus assez d'énergie
pour permettre un système de s'organiser
comme ils sont venus et m
alors ça c'est la ville dynamique alors
je vais vous donner une vue statique
dans l'ombre du lien entre l'énergie et
l'activité agricole
ce graphique est gradué avec en ordonner
au pourcentage de la population active
qui est de l'agriculture et en abscisse
la consommation d'énergie par habitant
chaque point représente un pays dont
d'accord dont ce point là par exemple
c'est un pays dans lesquels il a 30 %
des gens qui travaillent dans
l'agriculture et on est à peu près à
à 4 pardon c'est tard quatre corps
d'équivalent pétrole de consommation
énergétique par personne et par an ce
que vous voyez c'est que plus on
consomme d'énergie dans un pays et plus
la fraction des gens qui travaillent
dans l'agriculture et passe donc ça
c'est la version statique de ce que je
vous ai montré juste avant là où vous
voyez que au fil du temps avec
l'approvisionnement énergétique qui a
augmenté la fraction des individus qui
travaillent dans l'agriculture a baissé
à tracteur ça remplace une paire de
jambes par un tracteur de 70 km 100
chevaux s'avoue développe la même
puissance que huit paires demande pour
vous donner un tracteur un agriculteur
et où les d'être capable de nourrir lui
plus d'une demi personne à l'extérieur
de son chant des baleines est capable de
couvrir 100 personnes 8h08 puis cette
ville et ce club actuel voilà
et alors autre chose l'activation vous
pouvez retrouver le fait que la
tertiarisation de l'économie dont vous
avez vu dans cette vision dynamique
qu'elle arrive une fois qu'il ya plein
d'énergie et donc on peut mettre tout le
monde dans les services puisque toutes
les activités productives sont assurés
par des machines
eh bien on va la retrouver
si on prend une vision statique du monde
aujourd'hui est celle ci large avait un
graphique sur lequel en ordonner l'arrêt
des émissions en co2 par personne et par
an et en abscisse la fraction des actifs
qui travaillent au service et chaque
point représente appelé nombre donc ce
pays a par exemple ce au point par
exemple représente un pays où vous avez
25 tonnes de co2 émises par personne et
par an et vous avez à peu près 60% de la
population
travaillent dans les services ce que
vous voyez sur ce graphique c'est que
souhaiterait qu'ils mettent les gens
auront toujours de me permettre de faire
baisser les émissions de co2 le nuage de
points
il s'organisera en ligne descendante de
la gauche dans la droite
c'est à dire que plus vous avez de gens
dans les services et puis les émissions
de co2 par personne serait pas ce corps
quand nous n'avons pas encore venu de 36
de la soirée mais tous constaté que
c'est pas comme ça que le deux de pointe
organismes d'accord et si on doit voir
en avant si vous amuser à faire une
régression sur ce job points contre si
vous croisez les états unis dans les
académies dont la 80 % de l'emploi dans
les services
et comme chacun sait mais c'est des gros
cochon dégueulasse relations nous allons
respecter cette petite avance donc ce
que vous voyez là que vous voyez là
maintenant vous avez les ambiances
encore plus près à leur mode de vie que
les américains sont très rudes et le on
a beaucoup glosé sur les amis ce que
vous voyez là c'est le fait que l'it et
sympathique que mettre les gens dans un
bureau dans une sorte au pays du
pantalon impeccable au pied
ça va permettre de dématérialiser
l'économie et donc de faire moins de co2
par personne en fait c'est pas du tout
ça fait l'exact inverse tout simplement
parce que si vous êtes tous dans un
bureau c'est qu'à peindre la chine ce
qui veut dire aussi autre chose ça veut
dire que je suis raisonnablement
convaincus du fait que dans un monde
sous contrainte énergétique la part du
travail manuel ne va pas rappeler c'est
également bon on va transpirer plus pour
gagner moins
sarkozy avec moins d'argent
il a dit qu'on allait travailler plus
pour gagner plus relativement au fait
que paris et dans l'absolu jugement
quelle justice ad'ailleurs 25 30 ce que
je vous explique d'aucune de miage benno
schématiser maintenant de manière très
simple par opposition à la vision
économique conventionnelle et que vous
avez là je représente la manière dont
nos chers politiques et les biens
produits et nos avis d'avant centrale et
tous les académiques du monde économique
sauf exception tous les académies du
monde économique sauf exception voilée
dont l'économie à deux facteurs de
production le capital humain et de
travail encore plus heureux si vous avez
eu des cours d'économie à l'école c'est
ce que vous avez appris ça fait un
système productif et il en sort une
production si la production elle va à
ces éléments payer des retraites le
détache le travail je demande aux
banques de prêter les fonds investissent
le plus de capital les libéraux par
banca on a essayé cette recette encore
et encore depuis 35 40 ans ça marche lot
de moins en moins bien c'est pas aussi
simple que ça c'est pas aussi simple que
ça tout simplement parce que le système
ne s'organise pas comme cela le système
s'organise la manière suivante notre
système productif l'écu dès lors la
machine à transformer des ressources
avec une activité de transformation
comme je le disais tout à l'heure et par
définition du travail ou plus exactement
de l'énergie à l'époque nous n'avions
comme usq notre capacité de
transformation des ressources était de 1
est maintenant d'aller machine elle est
passé à 200 il ya toujours plein de sens
à transformer et à cali en tout cas
c'est pour faire des immeubles
ruth l'état pour les cumulards et
chercher dans l'environnement pour faire
des papillons et des villes est donc
notre machine économique
c'est juste une énorme machine à
transformer des ressources naturelles
dont je me rappelle qu elles sont
gratuites les ressources naturelles
c'est le fruit de 15 milliards d'années
d'évolution de typiquement pour lesquels
n'avaient pas payé un centime
rien nada quand oscar milliards d'années
d'évolution qui le big bang ça fait deux
générations des toiles la planète terre
tous les minerais que les éléments du
tableau sans délai y est fait d'un
système climatique à 2 c en le bagage
génétique de 30 millions d'espèces et un
crapaud l'enfant est vraiment bien joué
on n'a rien d'un coup tout ça en france
les supermarchés c'est génial dont
concert on transporte et ça fait des
produits tout ce que vous payez dans un
produit que vous achetez c'est une somme
rémunération que vous avez payé là des
hommes pour aller de ressources
gratuites un objet qui zappe que vous
achetez c'est tout ce que vous payez
c'est comme ça qu'ils fabriquent et le
système économique
donc quand vous achetez ce verre vous
payez tout sauf ce qui constitue le vert
tout le reste vous le payez vous payez
le mec qu'a chercher le pétrole du tracé
du plastique
vous payez le mec les chercher dinars
est d'ailleurs dû payer le mec qui a
extrait de minerai de fer qu'il a
transformés en guerriers vous payer tous
les ingénieurs de chez nous le berger
des techniques absolument ahurissante
des signaux restent absolument
merveilleux qui ont utilisé toutes ses
ressources pour extraire les matières
premières lui payer les gens d'arkema ne
serait peut-être bien qu'ils ont
construit des usines avec d'autres
socrates voilà ce que vous payez vous ne
payez pas beau mais ça ne paye pas son
truc et le gris marrast histoire alors
vous comprenez que si on a un goulet
d'étranglement sur l'énergie qu'on ne
regarde pas avant tel physiquement
j'avais donc un duel d'étranglement sur
une capacité de transformation et vous
allez avoir un goulet d'étranglement
la production science or si vous avez
moins d'énergie les moins payés ou
montré après que ça marche extrêmement
bien et si vous avez moins de ressources
de manière chacun vous aurez aussi moins
de payer alors je vais prendre un
exemple tout bête ce qui est celui de la
pêche c'est quoi la pêche l'extraction
des poissons de l'océan le poisson je
disais tout à l'heure le second est
arrivé gratuitement le bagage génétique
du poisson est arrivé gratuitement reste
toutefois ce moment-là graphiquement il
bedoui dans l'océan est un produit tout
ça et l'impression à pêcher des files
martinisme en étant une valeur géants
comme chantait en eau dont vous avez les
poissons qui arrivent spontanément dans
l'océan et le pc la valeur des poissons
extraites de l'océan avec des bateaux
alimentés au gasoil parce que si vous
essayez de faire avancer pas l'arabe le
chef du guilvinec qui sert à rien
imaginons que vous ayez une capitale
c'est à dire le bateau est osée du
travail c'est à dire ne parle que vous
ayez les ressources c'est à dire quoi ça
vous n'avez pas de gaz pas pris les
armes le chalutier du guilvinec marche
très bien imaginons maintenant que vous
ayez du capital c'est à dire les bateaux
du travail c'est-à-dire des bas rhin
éventuellement du gasoil ou s'en fout
pas de façon rapide et imaginons vous
ayez un four à ciment avec laquelle pas
de carrière dû extraire du catm
pratiquement pas de pays dont d'accord
donc les deux seules choses qu'on
regarde dans les conventions économiques
ordinaires
c'est à dire le capital humain et le
travail 1 sont justement de ce que les
deux choses qui sont aujourd'hui devenus
surabondante le travail à la place du
chômage partout la propre travail
pas trop par rapport à ce qu'on est
capable d'utiliser du capital à part
troupes ce que l'allemagne à d'abord été
on a trop de pognon et on a trop de
travail
par contre les deux trucs qu'on
surveille pas encore enceinte lui en
avoir assez pour que le système
d'individus comme avant de l'énergie aie
mais manque de pot céder d'autres
confirmés par 12
d'où cette idée de crise qu'on doit
ravir en fait les voit pas venir sont
utiles soutien économique standard
vous allez voir que les voit très bien
venir si on utilise l'énergie comme
proxy de la production à qui alors pour
ça je vais y avoir une règle de trois
j'espère que vous me pardonnerez la
règle de croire à cette heure tardive
vague de froid il commence avec quelque
chose de très simple qui était pib
mondial égale à 10 sur toi j'espère que
tant que nous n'avons pas vu ce qu'ont
encore d'accord jeudi viser se
multiplient le pib mondial par l'énergie
pour sa vie d'antan alors là je fais
apparaître à terme d'efficacité
énergétique de l'économie c'est quoi
l'efficacité énergétique de l'économie
c'est combien d'euros de valeur ajoutée
et je crée avec une minute et physique
de transformation du monde c'est à dire
une unité d'énergie
je transforme monde ça crée de la valeur
ajoutée avant j'avais du minerai après
j'avais la route au plus facile de
couper sa dernière couteau et devrait
faire donc je crée quelque chose mais
elle concède transformation j'ai utilisé
d'énergies plus je suis capable de créer
quelque chose qui m'est très utile donc
avec beaucoup de valeur ajoutée en ayant
utilisé peu de transformations physiques
peu d'énergie et plus mon économie est
considérée comme étant efficace et je
les soutenir paris match et je vais
ramener ça à la population si donc le
pib par personne c'est à la production
par personne soit dit en passant aussi
par personne pour ça que le pib devient
intéressant et bien assez strictement
égal à peu près strictement ya à
l'efficacité énergétique
économie fois la quantité d'énergie par
personne strictement rien si je fais une
dérive une dérive et bars alors si je la
fais si je prends les logan bailly s'est
toujours fortement jan si je prends les
variations on va dire que c'est une
égalité qui reste vrai au premier rang
ça veut dire quoi cette histoire ça veut
dire que la fameuse croissance du pib
par personne celle qui est promise par
tout candidat qui se respecte les
élections et des gares et à la variation
exactement la croissance quand on a de
l'énergie par personne plus la variation
de l'efficacité énergétique de
l'économie points n'a pas besoin de
modèles macroéconomiques complicité
jetables sortant mais qu'il a failli
encore l'énergie par personne voulait
montrer tout à l'heure c'était 2 10% par
an pendant un siècle avant 80
après c'est descendu à ions 4
l'efficacité énergétique de l'économie
ça fait quelques dizaines d'années le
sas parade aux alentours de 1% au moins
avec les phases variable et donc vous
devez vous attendre à théorie nous dit
que le pib par personne ne devait
augmenter de 30 % par an en moyenne
mondiale
à voir les chocs pétroliers et que
depuis ça doit être de l'ordre sans
tarder à trois personnes à temps sur ce
corner droit n'est pas la croissance du
pib total
et voilà ce que nous dit ce que vous
disent les chiffres connus par
l'institution et spectacles la banque
mondiale la banque mondiale se dit que
au moment des trente glorieuses le
président et par personne augmenter bien
à 3% par an en moyenne ce que vous avez
en bleu c'est la variation annuelle est
ce que vous avez en rouge c'est la
brienne barricades mais par des séismes
et aujourd'hui on se balade aux
alentours de quelque chose pour cent par
an donc là votre question c'est de
savoir
derrière on allait raser en plus c'est
au moins un fédéral alors voilà le
paysage d'un élément au dossier des
marches d'escalier sont plus partie ici
vous avez quelque chose des marches
d'escalier faible là elles sont
significativement plus marqué là on
avait deux pays il vient et là vous avez
des pays où ceux par départements
donc de deux choses l'une où vos
politiques sont aussi stupides que les
nôtres où il ya une raison structurelle
d'être ensemble d'accords est dehors
voilà une autre manière de présenter
quelque chose
objectivement voilà un autre résultat
attendu dans ce que je vous ai dit un
appartement où la capacité de
transformation est essentiellement liée
non pas en nous nos gens qui travaillent
l'énergie lui qu'on a on s'attend à voir
un pays l'écho variés comme l'énergie
c'est très exactement ce qu'on observe
ainsi vous avez dans le monde depuis 65
en faire la variation de la quantité
d'énergie consommée et englos la
variation du pib mondial et vous avez
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
cohérent avec ce que je lui dis alors
certes vous avez votre manière toujours
de présenter le même résultat sur ce
graphique ce nuage de points
représentent de 1965 à 2011
donc là ce 65 grâce à deux de bronze
pour le monde dans son ensemble en
abscisse la consommation d'énergie et en
ordonnée le pays de milliane est ce que
vous voyez ci dessus du haj de poing
s'organise de manière absolument
remarquable de longvic droite dis moi
combien du concept des nervis je te
dirais même à payer alors il ya des étés
de bord lié notamment au fait que les
flux physiques qui concerne de l'énergie
cre va avoir lieu en dehors du pays où
était le pib qui en résulte
vous avez une activité de négoce
j'achète une cargaison de blé à
singapour et je la revends la nouvelle
orléans qui avait encore là bas eh bien
j'ai empocher la plus-value qui en
résulte alors que l'énergie physiquement
correspond à la valeur ajoutée s'est
élargie traction du bateau qui va de
singapour à la nouvelle orient et ça
peut pas passer en suisse simon
régression a qu'en suisse donc quand
vous regardez un pays pris isolément
vous avez des effets de bords peuvent
perturber cette corrélation mais si vous
regardez le monde dans son ensemble
c'est absolument spectaculaire par
contre et là je dis perturbée aussi au
niveau mondial et j'insiste là dessus
qu'il n'y a pas de corrélation entre le
prix de l'énergie et le grill
c'est quoi le bad boy
c'est un résoudre un point par en 1966
2011la en abscisse le prix du pétrole
et il faut savoir que les 3/4 de la
dépenser
l'équipe dans le monde en énergie
primaire c'est des pétroles d'accord et
jusqu'à une époque récente en plus dans
la totalité des régions du monde de prix
des autres énergies c'est à dire gaz et
charbon était indexé sur celui du
pétrole
en gros regardez de que du pétrole et
vous avez la dépense énergétique
mondiale
et bien ce que vous disent graphique
c'est que le prix du pétrole qui peut
descendre montent et descendent remonter
ça ne change pas l'orientation de fond
du pib pour le moment d'accord la route
prix du pétrole descend et le pays des
vans wheels prix du pétrole montent et
démontent une prix du pétrole descend un
pib mensuel prix du pétrole indique
jacques bouille autour d'une valeur
constante et payer long puis prix du
pétrole montaient très haut niveau
mondial
pourquoi au niveau mondial que le
pétrole il ya un âge de rien voilà donc
si le vendeur l'après pétrole explose
adjacents et chic
donc ça change pas ce qui change
encore une fois ceux qui pilotent le pib
mondial si la quantité la quantité
le prix c'est secondaire alors le prix
bas car beaucoup souffrir les
importateurs qui viendra après par
contre au niveau mondial encore une fois
plus vous payez cher il attend
récompense
et puis le vent dans les voiles enfin
dernier point est ce que je vais vous
montrer là et voilà pour tous les pays
dans black
vous avez ici alors ça c'est drame de
l'ingénieur je peux vous dire tout de
suite hein parce que l'ingénieur il est
vachement content quand il est venu il
ya un objet qui consomme moins d'énergie
pour rendre service si ça y est j'ai
sauvé la balle est allée le voir tout
compliquer vous avez ici pour les états
unis depuis 1950
à 52 ans inclus ans le pays est en bleu
la consommation d'énergie en roja et
l'endettement public et privé droite au
moment où pib et énergie cette équipe
c'est un peu d'énergie cela
d - le pib à ce moment vous voyez que
leur rupture de pente sur
l'accroissement de l'endettement et ses
prêts très exactement le moment où vous
avez votre point d'inflexion sur
l'approvisionnement en afrique par
personne alors j'ai pas le temps
malheureusement de rentrer dans les
détails ce soir j'ai un certain nombre
de travaux qu'elle évite qu'ils sont en
cours sur cette question il est assez
vraisemblable que la résulte de l'autre
parce qu'à partir du moment où vous
n'avez plus assez d'énergie pour assurer
la présence physique que vous aviez
avant que vous allez essayer de relancer
l'économie notamment par les
investissements dont vous allez demander
aux gens de s'endetter pour acheter et à
l'équipement pour que la production
reparte
et comme vous n'avez pas l'énergie pour
que la production repart à la production
de repas repas elles restent avec leur
dette sur les bras c'est exactement
pareil pour les états vous avez embauché
l'état fonctionnaires que vous pouvez
pas dire est qu'ils ont augmenté de 3%
par an à l'époque où tout allait bien qu
au moment où les choses vont moins bien
de continuer à avoir besoin de payer 3 %
par an de plus tous les ans et vous avez
besoin de vous endetter pour assurer sa
part les fonctionnaires sont des gens
idiots c'est juste que le système a été
construit pour être efficace dans
l'accélération et quand vous avez une
décélération ombre à développer dehors
qui apparaissent et d'endettement
et comme je pense qu' il n'y aura plus
l'activité économique croissance
permettant de rembourser la dette
la conclusion de gentillesse et
parvenant à dos et il reste que le
financier avait la carte peut être c'est
à dire de ce qui valait 100 la veille 0
lendemain toute la question est de
savoir ça peut amener doucement dans
cette inflation et ça peut arriver plus
notamment cette équipe
donc ce que je vous ai expliqué depuis
le début de cette intervention c'est que
en gros le monde moderne dans lequel ils
vivent on est vraiment issu de ce cadeau
merveilleux que la nature nous a fait
graphiquement parce que j'insiste
pétrole est aussi gratuite le vent il
est aussi gratuite que l'on vous n'avez
rien payer pour la formation du pétrole
rien vous payez vos meilleurs moments
mais je vous signale que si vous voulez
accéder à des vents aussi au prix d'un
dépenses des vidéos viennent égayer les
clans qui possède le charme des plantes
et des olé donc le pétrole est aussi
gratuite le vent par contre il s'extrait
de l'environnement avec beaucoup moins
de travail par kilowattheure que
l'énergie du vent donc c'est normal
by considérablement moins chers que les
bergers du plant et juste de la physique
le pauvre d'affaires biologique chez
parfois c'est juste de la physique la
nature conduit une énergie concentrée
merveilleuse et enfin tous les jeunes
qui sont dans la pièce choisie c'est
bien ma conjointe parce que quand on
divorce augmente la consommation de
l'énergie les ex conjoints et 60% deux
fois plus de logements c'est l'une des
raisons de la crise du logement dans les
pays occidentaux
quant à démographie par la baisse deux
fois plus d'objets de la vie courante à
fabriquer des tables des chaises des
machines à laver des télévisions et ses
deux fois plus d'énergie de chauffage
damman quelques trajets pour les gosses
quand fernand il d'augmenter la
consommation d'énergie des ex conjoints
de l'ordre de 50% dans un monde sous
contrainte énergétique alors ça se
manifestera par une contrainte
économique évidemment on vivre sera plus
comme aujourd'hui il ya que dans les
pays de la léthargie qu'il en soit dit
en passant
dans les pays qui ont beaucoup d'énergie
en divorce par sais pas si la solution
est meilleure
voilà donc quand vous regardez bien vous
faites les forages à travers toutes les
couches que nous avons construite en un
siècle et demi ou rendez compte on
retrouve l'énergie à peu près partout à
peu près partout dans l'occupation du
territoire c'est pareil les villes les
10 et alizé de l'énergie tous à cette
énergie
sauf si c'est donc l'énergie comme ça il
est dit en introduction
ce n'est pas un secteur économique
parcours c'est le sort de l'exosquelette
500 fois puissants comme nous qui nous a
permis de vivre dans le monde dans le
gaming c'est sale el sol il est à mon
sens ça me pose et qu'il faut s'en sont
trois appartements
voilà qu'on a fait quelque chose de
merveilleux avec les combustibles
fossiles
alors maintenant on va s'intéresser à
deux questions la première c est ce que
en même temps la fête continue et en ce
qui concerne l'extraction extra 300
c'est un peu mon but ce type de fossiles
et à une question aval qui va avec il
est combien de temps est-ce que je
rejette dans l'atmosphère une espèce
chimiques qui a la mauvaise idée de la
mode qui a eu la bonne idée est absorbée
co2 qui n'en serait pas là
il ya aussi la mauvaise idée de la forme
et de co2 si on en met trop ces choses
avant que le résultat de l'expérience le
soir plus désagréable que l'idée qu'on
s'en fait alors je vais traiter
rapidement les deux questions la
première je rappelle que les énergies
fossiles ont un temps de formation qui
est de l'ordre de la centaine de
millions d'années donc aux échelles de
temps il nous intéresse que considérer
qu'il ya un stock de départ qui donne
une fois pour toutes alors on peut sans
faille et en 2h savoir que les attaques
du stock il me reste des gens qui
m'appellent le faire la seule chose qui
m'intéresse pas ce que je vais vous dire
après c'est que le stock de départ à
donner son avis juste ça parce que quand
vous avez un stock de départ qui donne
une forme tout ce qui est vrai pour les
gros carburant mais aussi pour les grecs
vous avez appris à être qu' on ne peut
pas avoir une extraction appel indique
une croissance
il rappelait m vous ne pouvez même pas
avoir une extraction adwya lille 1
l'énigme en constante en fait des
montées en carélie qu'en pareil cas la
valeur moyenne de votre fonction
elle est nulle sur n'importe quel un
permanent bull et mieux la brand
l'infini du la plus d'infini et passe
par un maximum en faune et en fait le
cumul de votre fonction c'est-à-dire la
surface sous la courbe la latérale
elle est au plus égal à la valeur du
stock est un type extractives vendredi
par des deux avait un stock de départ
est fixé une fois pour toutes
peu importe sa valeur vous auriez un
maximum à l'extraction année donc vous
auriez vous aurez un pic à la production
mondiale de pétrole 12 ans et un pic à
la production mondiale de gaz aurait
impliqué la production mondiale de
minerai de cuivre de pastel vanadium
chronique n faire même beyond the style
est pour rien trois questions toujours
les règles alors ça en termes de méthode
pour les ingrédients futurs ingénieurs
jeune société [ __ ] quant au plus tard à
quel niveau
et est-ce que c'est grave de passer de
manière involontaire ou est ce que c'est
une catastrophe
madeira c'est ça les travestis encore de
fait il ya un pic du pape pie xi un
torrent de battre considéré avec des
rames de battre 2-1 manning en floride à
nous déplaît en est que je doute donc
trois questions les trois hommes un an
au plus tard à quel niveau au plus haut
des conséquences
est ce qu'il faut le provoquer est ce
qu'il faut là dedans mais savoir gérer
il faut l'anticiper fois encore tracé
des questions alors les pics sont
faciles à prévoir qui sont déjà passés
voilà un flic facile à prévoir parce
qu'il est déjà passée c'est celui des
découvertes le gaz et pétrole
il est survenu à peu près
le ma naissance tessier elizabeth ii ce
que vous voyez c'est que les découvertes
mondiales d'hydrocarbures gaz et pétrole
passés dans un maximum dans les années
à l'échelle de ce graphique qui est en
milliards de baril équivalent pétrole
les découvertes que vous avez
actuellement au large du brésil c'est de
cet ordre là
le sol profond là que vous avez au large
du brésil essaie de l'en de cet art
alors je peux vous dire que paris dément
cette expression très noir il ya marin
petrobras va se faire absolument certain
ça ne changera que très marginalement le
destin ou gagnent ça changera énormément
le destin des actionnaires de petrobras
s'ils sont pas tenté d'enlever également
voilà un pronostic qui a été fait par
des géants pétroliers que je connais sur
un quoi pourrait ressembler la
production mondiale mais liquide alors
en sommes là et là vous avez une
agrégation de ce qu'on appelle le
pétrole conventionnel ici vous avez
l'offshore profond dans typiquement le
soft a pour origine la volaille et les
cochonneries canal hier et les
cochonneries vénézuélienne est
extrêmement de l'orénoque
ici vous avez des multiples garages sont
des condensats qui sortent du gaz quand
on extrait et on voit la question du
pétrole ne peut importer là vous avez là
deux garnements le tholy quizz etc
en gros des plaques à trois ans ça sera
peut-être dans dix ans enfin je vais
vous dire non à l'europe via la radio j
5 la question qui vient à l'esprit de
tout le monde en général c'est qu'est-ce
que ça va valoir
je vous l ai dit tout à l'heure c'est
pas un sujet pour le pib mondial et ses
taux pendant un sujet pour le pib
mondial que si vous essayez de regarder
les prévisions les projections passé sur
le prix futur
alors là par contre autant prévoir le
pique futures découvertes place et
c'était facile autant prévoir le prix
futures du pétrole
c'est une mission impossible vous avez
aussi un peu d'activité
ap
les rapports griaule agence
internationale de l'énergie tous les ans
sort un truc s'appelle le world energy
outlook dans lequel il donne la vision
du pré fusion de pétrole sur va pas
alors un rouge vous avez sur cette
courbe ce que le prix a vraiment été et
là vous avez ce que les yeux a dit en
la seconde est en 2001 place du mondial
2002 date à dire le droit
répondeur de classe ils continuent mais
les analystes continuent à en parler
donc comique troupier prévisionnistes
les friches de la niveleuse pareil dit
n'importe quoi les gens me disent tu
continues à fêter ce que vous dites
personne ne peut savoir ce que sera leur
culture déblocables toute personne alors
maintenant ça fait pas les affaires si
vous avez besoin d'y mentionner un
projet si vous avez besoin d'immenses
hainard projets d'entraidé et l'âme et
ils filent et in fine les décideurs fait
son métier
la punition mais l'idée on prend une
décision sur la base d'un fi centrale
dont on est sûr de ses seins l'autre
surtout pas là
par ailleurs les cris ne donne pas les
volumes de notre plume pour l'humain
vous avez ici un graphique qui a éveillé
à la crème temps où vous avez chaque
point représente pour un mois donné
alors entre 98 et 2004 dans les points
gris et entre 2005 et 2011 pour les
points noirs à la fois la quantité de
pétrole produite pendant roi et le prix
du baril de pétrole sur une grande
question
ce que vous voyez cette entre 98 et 2000
5 vous avez une élasticité prix volume
si vous faites une cour de régression là
dessus pas plus le prix augmente et plus
le volume augmente de dix autres avant
voudrait une forme d'élasticité et
évoluent là y en a plus c'est à dire que
le volume il est fixe à 74 millions de
barils/jour et le prix est-il si vous
utilisez les chairs modèles créés par
les cris les économistes favoris donc
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure il ne vous
donne pas évolué
alors j'ai parlé du pétrole qui va
passer son pic
est-ce qu'on en émoi alors observé dans
le passé récent vous avez ici
l'évolution de la production de pétrole
depuis 65 avant le choc après les chocs
et depuis 2005
on est à quasiment zéro on est à
quasiment zéro tendon si vous prenez les
payant cdo
quand la maman est venue lors d'une
sommation donc depuis 2005 année où la
consommation ou la production mondiale
plafonne au ils font ça donc vous vous
attendez à ce que les pays en deux lots
et des oeufs leur consommation face
c'est que la disponibilité en pétrole
des pays ocde a commencé à décliner je
ne vois pas de raison de penser que sa
croissance et donc vous allez vivre et
je lui ai dit non parce que j'espère que
les masses encore quelques semaines à
vivre dans un monde dans lequel on va
avoir de prise en main de pétrole
indépendants mais qui leur note
ce n'est pas la question la question
c'est qu'est ce qui fait qu est ce qui
fait qu on a souvent entendu dire que le
pétrole s'était pas un problème parce
qu'il y avait moins de pétrole au phare
polar de pib aujourd'hui que ça donnait
le carré chante fait saviez ce que tu as
fait bref c'est parce qu'on temps pour
les données - les membres
vous avez si la consommation de pétrole
du monde et ici son pays lé la série de
points vers présent 65 à 60 89 avec ici
74 à 79
et si vous avez 2003 2011
eh ben vous voyez que avant vous aviez
de droite comme ceux ci après vous avez
une boîte comme cela vous avez toujours
droite
dit autrement la quantité de pétrole et
le pédiatre toujours extrêmement
fortement coréens ont été cassées des
parapentes de la droite s'est amélioré
et contrairement à l'idée qu'on se fait
souvent en hausse à pas moins de pétrole
quand on est en crise d'abord on a moins
de pétrole et ensuite
triste que vous pouvez voir sur cette
route en rougit si vous avez la
variation de la consommation mondiale de
pétrole et en bleu vous avez la
variation du pib par personne
la période qui m'intéresse et surtout la
l'envoyait café les champs pétroliers on
a resserré l'écart entre les deux tours
dit autrement l'économie mondiale
réagissent plus fortement à une
variation données de l'approvisionnement
en pétrole et monbahus faiblement réagi
plus fortement donc l'économie mondiale
plus dépendance qu'elle ne l'était en 64
d'une variation donné que la production
de pétrole ont valeur absolue c'est
normal puisque l'économie et plus
efficace sur son usage du pétrole si
vous en avez un peu ça supprime plus de
pays d c'est paradoxal c'est comme ça
est ce que vous voyez également ici
c'est que la variation sur le pétrole
pressel la variation sur le pib et la
suite par dix autres avant d'abandonner
moins de pétrole et ensuite payer des
impôts style à bord vraiment étrange
ensuite le bébé ça on va prendre trois
pays d'europe qui en ce moment font un
peu la une des journaux on va commencer
par la grèce
qui d'entre nous dans cette salle la
porte je lui parlais de la bascule des
gens vous avec la grèce en ce moment à
quelques petits plaisirs économique
voilà la consommation d'énergie primaire
la grèce alors ce que vous voyez d'abord
s'occuper tant de prix tout la grèce et
le pétrole est le pays européen dont le
pétrole qui a la charge la plus
importante pour le pétrole dans son
métier d'avocat 60 quand guy lambert
ce que vous voyez également c'est que le
pétrole commence à décliner en 2006 2006
d'accord maintenant voici le pib grec le
pib grec en 2006 il était là donc
d'abord le pétrole décline le pib
continue à montech
ensuite le pib des filles comme on sait
pas moins de pétrole parce que crise et
d'avoir 24 heures ensuite ce que vous
voyez ici ces mêmes pratiques que je
vous ai présenté tout à l'heure pour le
monde sait que l'efficacité pétrole les
connaît
y a pas été modifié après les chocs
pétroliers ils sont restés aussi très
efficaces dans leurs usages de pétrole a
pas les chocs pétroliers qu'il l'était
avant de rajouter au fait qu'ils ont 60%
de pétrole dans leur mix énergétique
notamment à cause de la place de
tourisme arrive la contrainte sur la
production mondiale de pétrole la baisse
du pétrole dans la famille au mans break
et bon l'économie grecque par l'espagne
voilà mondialement énergétique l'espagne
ils avaient tous entendu dire que
l'espagne était un pays merveilleux où l
éolienne et ses amis vont et viennent
enfin de l'oci pour le pétrole voilà là
le pétrole consommé en espagne
pareil l'espagne n'a pas fait progresser
en efficacité énergétique en matière de
pétrole depuis 65 et après le moment où
le pétrole commence à décliner ses 2007
voilà le pib espagnol en 2007 l'a
d'abord ensuite le pib des saints voilà
donc l'espagne a fait un peu de progrès
mais pas par goût et voilà le craindre
un glissement en 2007
et bien maintenant intéressant de one
drop voilà l'approvisionnement pétrolier
de l'europe dans lequel génie en rose la
production de la mer du nord
je vous signale que les prix du pétrole
ont commencé à s'envoler en 2000 et vous
voyez que c'est pile de moment où la
production de la mer du nord décline
donc le discours que vous entendez
parfois dire qu'il ya écrit you man donc
la production augmente parce que les on
va investir d'état pas mal de moulis
lorsque tombent parfois et envers vous
avez les importations salariés je confie
tessin et en valais vous avez les
implantations qui représente aujourd'hui
70 % si la grève si la grèce l'union
européenne et la norvège
pour l'exemple
rech il enlève à l'envers il ya 90 300
d'importation en iran on va dire que la
norvège ça fait quand même partie de
blocs géopolitiques
ce que vous voyez c'est l'europe a perdu
10% de son pétrole depuis 2007
d'abord l'europe a commencé à perdre du
pétrole ensuite voilà 2008
ça se casse la gueule or donc ça marche
très bien
alors reste à théoriser tout ça reste à
comprendre pourquoi l'économie si
sensible aux variations du pétrole
j'ai quelques idées notamment le fait
qu'aujourd'hui a pas une activité
productive qui puisse se priver de
transport soient pensés pour 10 heures
soit pour ses clients si vous avez moins
de pétrole vainement de transport en
train dé - à la une explication possible
clic il faut faire garder sa traque
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que on a des
bandes armées y aurait évidemment
l'efficacité pétrole mais si ça doit
continuer ce que je vous ai montré là
mon sentiment c'est qu'il est
aujourd'hui raisonnable de dire
politique que il faut qu'on lui propose
des plans à croissance nulle que les
autres ne l'est pas comment des gens de
produire complètement dans plusieurs
heures du mans proposez-nous des choses
qui soient compatibles avec pas de
croissance
ça veut pas dire pas de problème voilà
alors en plus nous on a un sujet balance
commerciale est donc un sujet tel vous
avez ici la facture énergétique de
l'union européenne
c'est donc la contrepartie monétaire de
l'énergie qu'on est
acheté à l'extérieur alors je sais pas
si vous savez les biens reviennent
importe déjà le champion l'allemagne et
la pologne importe la moitié d'un charme
oscille donc ça puisse paraître on
apporte des vies dans le métro la part
du gaz et ça ça nous ferait presque 100
milliards de dollars 150 milliards
d'euros à fin 2011
c'est une somme complète alors je vous
proposais de ce cri golo le premier
c'est celui là vous avez besoin que les
françaises dont un jeune en contrat
porte comme un bon sens avec ce vous
avez sur ce graphique
l'augmentation de la dette publique
entre 93 et 2011 dont vous voyez qu'on a
rajouté air de famille milliards d'euros
de dette publique
enfin on les presse de des italiens pas
n'importe quoi et si vous avez le total
du pétrole et les ja ce que nous à la
valeur monétaire du pétrole et du gaz
que nous avons dû acheter à l'extérieur
la france importe 99 64 ans les cadres
oui que si je prends la facture
c'est à dire l'argent qui est sorti à
l'extérieur plus les intérêts composés
des épargnants pas très loin d'arriver
au danger à l'état alors dans le toit la
france et on est une bande de
branquignols pour aller voir dans
sérieux et vous voyez que ça fait
différent
il ya une grosse structure années avant
le choix dans cette histoire et il est
bien évident que quand on a une économie
européenne qui reste fortement dépendant
des combustibles fossiles
je ne vois pas comment on peut échapper
à la récession
hurel un endettement qui n'augmente
encore faire confiance dans le monde
jusqu'au moment où il ya plus personne
qui ont perdu confiance en ce moment
cette fin de mercato touche quand
l'éditeur fait défaut et on tond à
m'enfuir
alors on n'a pas de pétrole mais aussi
des gaz dans le monde voilà pronostics
centrale fait par total sur
l'approvisionnement mondial
gardez vous voyez que où il pense que sa
va plafonner aux alentours de 2020 2025
nonobstant un développement des gaz non
conventionnel qui eux continuent à
croître continuellement à croître
pendant très longtemps et nous déclin
sur le reste fait plus que compenser la
croissance du non conventionnelles et
aucun positionnement potable par
ailleurs une autre pensionnaire ça
ressemble à ça alors je sais pas si vous
avez la possibilité de faire ça en
belgique
je ne suis pas complètement persuadé
qu'on ait la possibilité de faire ça
dans le bassin parisien
et je ne suis pas complètement persuadé
qu'on ait la possibilité de faire ça
dans les cdi vous savez ce mati ses
contreforts sud du massif central en
france voilà j'ai quelques doutes sont
les gaz non conventionnel en europe on
en reparlera peut-être au moment des
questions que c'est comme le
photovoltaïque c'est beaucoup un sujet
pour nous voilà travail au noir mais en
gaz la mer du nord a passé son pic en
2005 40% du gaz est rapportée est parti
à la baisse du quota tellement comment
savourer sur le long terme c'est clair
de manière consciente et voilà
l'approvisionnement total en europe et
donc ça ça baisse sa sagesse sa certain
nombre de pays ont décidé de le faire
baisser
moi je veux bien de ça ça se mette à
compenser tout leur être là aussi
techniques restent charge alors le
charbon il est partout sauf en france
vous avez ici les réserves de chars dont
vous avez les huit premiers détenteurs
dans le monde qui sera et le reste du
monde
et ouais y'a un pays européen dans le
top weight qui est le huitième et il a
essentiellement
le charmant dégueulasse s'appelle unis
dit c'est les deux frères ennemis de
toujours qui possède les premières
réserves de change et d'autre des
réserves de charbon sont détenus par les
états unis et la loi voilà comment
évolue la consommation charme dans le
monde ça c'était un truc qui peut vous
intéresser aussi donc ici vous avez des
pays de la cedeao jouer les flatteries
m'attend ici les pays hors ocde en chine
et la moyenne donc c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne là où est ce que vous avez eu
entre 2000 et 2006 si vous enlevez le
charbon en chine
le reste ces plaques ici vous avez les
réserves agrégé gaz pétrole charbon par
pays est le premier pays en bien et là
le 12e filet si je finis ce panorama sur
les réserves
il ya plein de charbon dans le monde
encore pareil nous pétrole de gaz
continuent donc l'europe dès à présent
elle est sous stress de recettes des
lapins ce qui veut dire que tout ce
qu'on va avoir à vendre aux autres nos
serveurs sont les arbres tout ce qu'on
peut la rendre service enfin je vais
finir avec un fer la peep aggravation
changement climatique
ça va très vite la génération
voilà pourront évoluer les émissions de
co2 planétaire discriminés par nrj je
laisserai la présentation vous aurez
temps d'y revenir
voilà à quoi ressemble les éditions par
source
aujourd'hui de commentaires là dessus si
j'additionne les émissions des centrales
à charbon et des centrales à gaz
toujours et 25% des émissions
planétaires c'est à dire presque deux
fois les émissions des transports
donc si je prendrais quand vous
construisez une centrale à charbon leur
web 40 ans rappelle donc aujourd'hui au
niveau mondial l'enjeu central de la
négociation climat c'est d'empêcher les
gens poursuit lé centre à la chambre
savoureux centrale à l'initiation qui va
empêcher les gens d'acheter des voitures
se fût naissance avec dedans alors à
tourner l'industrie automobile
ça fait appeler comité matériel donc le
lac ainsi statut et en matière
climatique un truc aussi sur lequel il
faut insister c'est que l'activité
agricole de son stage puisque
l'essentiel de la déforestation vision
devenir des terres agricoles
c'est un tiers des émissions auxquelles
j'y reviendrai ça c'est bien des
questions c'est juste pour dire que la
variation qu'on est susceptible
d'infliger au système climatique juste
simple commenté quand même parce que ça
sera portant l'abaya sûrement les
sceptiques d'infusion
climatique c'est à dire de l'ordre de
quelques degrés en un siècle est
totalement hors norme
comparé à la variation naturelle du
système alors je réponde aux organismes
deux êtres vivants à poisson rouge et le
poisson rouge
je sais pas si certains d'entre vous
essayé de tuer le croissant-rouge
l'enfant de cette manière ça marche pas
m'aider dans l'autre et 3/10 survie vous
mettez dans votre édition lille à un
organisme qui est fait pour que une
variation de sa température interne
quelques degrés qui centre en foot il se
porte très bien merci
donc si cet organisme vous lui infligez
délibérément une variation de quelques
degrés de sa température interne il est
fait pour ça ils sont alors prenez un
être humain mais inflige el-aryath ion
de sa température interne de quelques
degrés bas ou la save a réuni 0 3 degré
paroisse de la température interne des
fois on vous lui infligez variations de
température avec les données des traders
parce qu'il n'est pas fait pour ça eh
bien le système climatique n'est pas
fait pour rester stables avec qui paris
seconde de sa température de quelques
degrés en un siècle n'est pas fait pour
ça il est fait pour rester stables avec
une variation de sa température quelques
fractions de degrés en quelques milliers
d'années ça il sait faire quelques
d'ailleurs assez qui s'établit à quelque
degré de variation de la température
c'est l'équivalent d'une des glaciations
quand on est passé du maximum de la
dernière relation
c'est plus froid a aujourd'hui la
planète de se réchauffer que de 5,2 si
vous devez retenir un chiffre un seul
sur le changement climatique en décidant
quand on passe d'un monde recouvert de
placier sur la scandinavie où la
belgique ressemble au nord de la sibérie
actuelle au nord de la sibérie actuelle
au monde moderne
l'élévation de température planétaire
c'est juste 5 degrés juste quand je vous
ai dit ça je pense que je vous aime à
peu près de 10 sur le changement
climatique
c'est à dire que 5 degrés de l'aria sion
en un siècle vous engendre un monde
chaotique violent très bien ingérable
j'ai juste une affaire de plus en plus
en moins je prends toi là quand ce
qu'elle vaut et de ring dans tout est
désorganisé tout parce que c'est un
changement d'une ampleur absolument
massive
la dernière fois que c'est arrivé notre
espèce que les 5 millions d'individus
qui est pas la délègue son sac à dos
n'avait pas de revendications sociales
des bruyères à temps vous appliquez le
même genre de plaisanterie à une
humanité c'est dans ta recette de
sédentaires par membres 7 u 9 milliards
d'individus qui vous pouvez pas aller
nulle part sans déranger quelqu'un en
général quelqu'un déranger il est
absolument évident ce que ça attisera
des conflits à peu près partout et si
j'avais tendance à expliquer en quoi le
printemps arabe et terminant climatique
qui est déjà extrêmement fort dès quand
on fait les gros yeux je vais m'arrêter
là j'avais un petit truc sur lequel je
reviendrai
vraiment
qui maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on fait
c'était une des questions principales
que vous avez soulevé
je pense qu'on doit digérer chiffres
développement de l'éducation bien cramé
souvent des rues de troyes il est déjà
passé
donc je pense qu'il serait intéressant a
maintenant c'est d'avoir une autre
question par rapport à ce qu'on a
entendu ici il pas la faire trop longue
qui sont précisent lentement si vous
avez développé sachant qu ici le but de
cette présentation c'est un constat donc
c'est intéressant d'aller dans les
questions par rapport aux constats les
aspres et solutions on va développer la
prochaine conférence est plutôt au
niveau du constat par rapport aux
hypothèses que vous avez pris la
solution elle sera jamais cantonnée à
d'autres techniques
la solution allopass par les discussions
économiques elles passent par des
discussions sur d'équipé elle passe par
des discussions sur la solide et de la
solidarité une porte aux générations à
venir il ya un milliard de plus qui
renvoie à la culture à notre morale etc
si c'était juste c'est une question que
le vélo qu'elle voulait vous avez pu
redémarrer très dense est dans cette
présentation je pense qu'on est l'être
humain est tout à fait absent ces deux
machines chez les ppc des kilowattheures
et c'est vrai que
technique on nous présente ici est une
chose la danse on est dans un cycle ici
qui rassemble des étudiants ingénieurs
de des ingénieurs principalement mais il
faut aussi que il n'oublie pas que de
rester ça y est des hommes des êtres
humains ceux qui veulent vivre vivre
bien et que la technique doit aussi
tenir compte de cet élément là alors moi
j'ai envie de poser la première question
avant de donner le micro à la cei c'est
inhumain ray de dents vous avez un peu
déjà commencé dans cette chose mais
voilà si vous pouviez vous préciser
quelques points quelle est la place de
l'humain donc dans ce constat elle et
elle est de lui donner des éléments dont
il est souhaitable que je compte pour
organiser des produits qui restent avec
énormément de la liberté tous les élèves
ingénieurs qui sont dans la salle si on
leur apprend la première fois de la
thermos a dit pas quel métier ils vont
faire avec les mariés dans quels pays
ont vibré à quel âge de juste ils savent
que s'ils vont faire des projets qui
violent la première heure d'interview ça
marchera pas juste ça donc là ce que je
voulais raconter c'est un certain nombre
de choses qui ne supprime pas ce que
nous sommes simplement si on essaye de
faire des plans pour l'avenir qu'ils
violent des choses ce sont des faits
documentés venir
c'est des limites de la physique
nucléaire et d'identité alors un autre
truc que je voudrais dire c'est que je
pense que les gens qui au motif qu'ils
sont experts dans un tonnerre propose
une solution en ce qui concerne les
choix collectifs outre pas ça roule j'ai
hâte les personnels comme citoyen l'état
dandy et les tas d'activités délitant
dans ce domaine mais à ce moment je vous
parle du constat je vous parle ce que
personnellement je france pertinent
faire pour la collectivité mais à ce
moment je reste est marrante citoyen je
ne paie plus en tant que personne qui
est capable d'actionner les
kilowattheures et à chaque fois et ça
c'est ils sont partis donc on va dire
2002 mais quand vous avez les mêmes
journalistes qui traitent la science et
la faction militants de la population
qui s'intéressent au problème
vous avez une confusion des gens
absolument monstrueuse empêche d'ivoire
est donc toute l'importance d'avoir la
mixité des approches couteau toujours
des sciences du ici une soirée spéciale
east d
et on va dire les quarante agents mais
servent d'armes pour établir le mât les
airs d'anciennes lui donne à s qualité
sur le fait que le nucléaire c'est le
client de l'un vers l'autre passe de
mettre de compétences
je voulais pas que ça arrive
la confusion des genres et en
particulier les journalistes qui sont
des gens pressés et qui ont des
questions à large spectre parce que
c'est les questions du citoyen
quand ils tiennent un expert 20 domaines
qu'ils ont rêvé de laurent gerra ce
qu'ils aiment bien faire c'est me poser
toutes les questions qu'ils passent par
la tête et c'est compliqué pour laquelle
sa part favori en battant les dames donc
je vous demanderais nous poser des
questions dont domaine du sanwi cas ce
que c'était les avis sur tout justement
la réponse je préciserai éventuellement
ce qui relève des habitants vit comme
individus et ce qui relève des choses
donc je vois déjà une main qui se
souvient il ya une en vente le
microcrédit vous dire que la
présentation de la conférence
donc l'espace public justement ces mises
ensemble dans un projet de recherche des
sciences dures et sensuelle où il ya
vraiment cette mixité la proche qui
était vraiment importante pour justement
la réflexion tout d'énergie mais sa
parole en soirée
intéressant question était la suivante
haute et très bien en évidence le lien
clair entre la consommation d'énergie et
les chaînes privées
la crise nous a menés très clairement en
évidence le fait que la disponibilité
d'énergie allait être contraint de
prendre ces mêmes si on exclut cette
session qui sont capables de ses
contacts à haut niveau mondial relay
raisons climatiques
on peut pas se permettre de continuer
avec les énergies fossiles dans ma tête
je pense qu'il a montrés elle était
assez sceptique sur la montée en
puissance contre évidemment rapide et
d'énergies renouvelables non
conventionnelles donc ma question c'est
voyez votre menu clé une solution éviter
des passants hausse trop rapide pib avec
tout ce que cela implique et en sachant
aussi que
les souvenirs des situe très très long
et que je ne vois absolument pas
personnellement comment avec ces sites
ne peut compenser la décroissance des
énergies fossiles et donc la question
finale s'est agi d'une solution en
dehors d'une relocalisation de comploter
l'économique à la finale parce que je le
frappe alors il n'y a pas de questions
j'y gagne dans votre affaire
je vais essayer données de quelques
règles avec lesquelles personnellement
j'ai bâti ma réponse la première c'est
que tout sauf la guerre donc à chaque
fois que je pense que d'évolutions sully
nous emmène de manière trop brutale vers
le cas aux wilayas un risque majeur
guerre et je n'interprète pas autrement
que par la contrainte économique elle
même liée à la contrainte énergétique la
montée du populisme que l'on voit
partout en europe et dont le dernier
exemple via que nous est donné je pense
que vous avez quelques représentants de
cette espèce chiots en lâcher d'eau et
la dernière le dernier exemple a été
donné en italie il ya pas longtemps
c'est très homogène sur l'europe et
solide en passant le tea party aux états
unis voilà c'est quelque chose qui parle
un peu mon sentiment c'est qu'il ya un
risque désagrégation sociale fort à
suivre la ligue 2 caen sans rien faire
après quand je quand je disais tout à
l'heure les habitants ça n'existe pas
mon critère est toujours le même
comme l'énergie sans risque n'existe pas
la seule question est toujours la même
c'est est-ce qu'une énergie donné dans
le contexte dans lequel on utilise évite
plus de risques qu'avant tout c'est ma
grille de lecture
donc si ça il y plus de risques que ça
manquerait qu'ils achètent
si c'est jamais sans risque la vie est
pleine de risques on finit par en mourir
comme dj click mais aussi la belle sans
risque la question encore une fois c est
ce que j'ai le plus de risques que j'en
fais alors le nucléaire le moins
différent cette catégorie il évite plus
de risques qu'il tentait d'en créer sur
un pari star il en a vécu ce qu'il faut
faire
ça c'est pour laraque ministre avec le
nucléaire d'une manière générale je suis
partisan ou gérer en sérieux
sérieuse alors ça veut dire quoi gérer
en moi une sérieuse gueule écope sérieux
ça veut dire qu'à chaque fois au dépôt
droit un problème particulier exemple
comment faire fonctionner une baie dans
un prétexte dans lesquelles j'ai pas
plus d'argent j'ai moins d'énergie c'est
peu probable que la solution chez vous
ça soit naître les panneaux solaires sur
le toit à l'éolienne sur les toits ces
vieux d'isoler les bâtiments c'est
encore mieux de faire en sorte que de
temps en temps les étudiants déplacement
pour venir ici et c'est rarement la
solution au problème
elle passe par des méthodes et une quand
dire elle passe par un ensemble de
méthodes donc là tout à fait tort elle
ne passe jamais par une boîte passe
partout mais achetait d'abord ces
métiers là et maintenant c'est pareil
j'étais bien qu'il ya un certain nombre
de constructeurs de boîte en question
qui me disent que c'est comme ça que ça
marche
donc ça va vraiment être coup droit de
chaque pays de chaque situation de
chaque question posée il ya déjà trop de
trucs on peut faire qui est d'éviter
d'en rajouter dans les conneries
chez nous un projet en ce moment
d'aéroport l'emprise de breton alors il
faut savoir aussi soit dit en passant
que les gens qui prennent l'avion c est
riche il hérisse les fils de richard
d'étudiants ils sont encore pas très
riche que sinon c'est le fils du coach
donc les gens qui prennent l'avion du
siège pour moi je trouve assez farce
quand premiers ministres socialistes
fassent une infrastructure pour riches
rigoler mais donc des gens peut
commencer par arrêter les conneries et
ensuite un certain vie personnelle et
ensuite il ya une manière de prendre le
problème qu'on soit dans une usine dans
un pays dans une région dans une
collectivité dans une université chez
nous et c'est à vous aurez toujours un
cocktail de mesures techniques de
mesures économiques parce que quand vous
avez un bout de marché dans la manière
dont fonctionne l'économie
vous aurez besoin de signes aux prix ils
sont faits pour ça je vous donne un
exemple vous pouvez très bien avoir
mettre en place un impôt annuel sur la
détention d'une voiture qui soit très
fortement 300 en fonction de la
consommation de la voiture
si vous faites ça vous n'excluez pas de
mobilité motorisée de champagnole also
be there un petit machin points donc
vous empêcher la voiture en fiesta tu
conserver la voiture objet utilitaire
vous l'acceptez chrétien est grand parce
que la voiture
pardon encore de cette expression du
diable chez les hommes c'est un parcours
de québec et chez les femmes c'est
l'impression de la sécurité elle est
passée de 4,4 aux finances parce qu'elle
pense que comme ça dans votre en
sécurité quand il ment les vols donc le
donc ça ça n'a rien à voir que ça c'est
de l'humain 100% ça n'a strictement rien
à voir avec des considérations
techniques car votre voiture sur le cas
sur roulettes chinois se déplacent donc
le les objets pour limiter fortement la
consommation d'énergie et faire de
l'énergie
on les a après tout ça qui va faire
pleurer et pour finir sur le nucléaire
parle on a commencé est ce que vous êtes
c'est parce que de famille est que
c'était sur simple clic abidal quand le
coût du capital et 1 8%
le réacteur vedette qui les points en
moins de gens qui lui disent non d'areva
le pm ou crachins mégawattheure à 85,90
zoo un guide pour cent taux
d'actualisation est ce que vous savez
après ça descend à d'autres centres
d'actualisation 40e car le plus bas de
ce que les couleurs messines battons
pour des trucs centrale mais c'est ce
que je disais il faudra peur parce que
papa chez moi à passe aussi par là il
faut vingt ans parce que c'est dangereux
lui envoyant il faut vingt ans parce que
le capital et par des courses en mai à
huit chez les jets christian cotées en
bourse car ses conseils c'est donc à
cause de tout ça vous voyez bien que là
on est dans un contexte dans lequel
s'est pas juste la technique le sujet
c'est tout un ensemble de trucs qu'on à
faire dissoudre modèle que lui dit oui
le modèle économique si je vous donne
les grandes lignes alors l'âge
maintenant il ya qu'à faut qu'on mais
après dans les grandes lignes il faut
absolument des financiarisé la
financiarisation de l'économie est un
poison mortel le sujet dont on parle
parce que sarah possi les horizons de
temps ou pas dramatique dont vous faites
plus rien 50 ans l'économie
financiarisée 50 ans ça n'existe que si
on financière les allégations de nos
gosses qui sera fait la sortie d'
amateur donc fait plus rien la deuxième
règle c'est que c'est qu'il faut faire
un grand soir fiscal
il se trouve que j'ai aussi un petit
patron - je pense qu'on payait ses
impôts par contempler les 352 différents
à 40
impôts donc je pense que l'on a vraiment
besoin d'un grand soir fiscal avec un
basculement très fort de la fiscalité de
ce qui nous emmerde pas parce qu'ils le
tampon
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut des taxes
et de travail et il faut taxer les
énergies fossiles entre autres choses la
consommation de ressources
l'espace occupé il faut aller vers des
niveaux de stocks si votre pib si on met
à se casser la gueule tous les impôts
qui sont prélevés sur une fraction du
pib allait avoir un petit sujet pour
faire tourner la puissance publique
donc il vaut mieux passer sur des impôts
de stoke - pour pas rentrer avant ça
revient pas capital investi suivante
donc voilà c'est sûr c'est intéressant
quand je me regarde la diversité
d'articles d'interviews et dont je vous
les donne pas c'est une question un peu
flou demeure une icône n'aime pas ceux
qui le demandent et dans quel état
donc il faut beaucoup d'imagination
cependant dans les solutions qu'on leurs
questions techniques financions au sort
merci pour votre présentation
une question sur les énergies
renouvelables donc les énergies fossiles
s'épuisent en europe
on doit les importer donc on va devoir
investir
les énergies renouvelables une des
solutions qui engendre sitôt des
investissements et des problèmes de
stockage
quel est votre avis et est ce que vous
imaginez ça comme un luxe pour l'europe
il ya une chose qui est absolument
certaine c'est que l'énergie ma chère
comme je disais tout à l'heure
de toute façon on en ressort de toutes
façons l'énergie vérité plus cher la
question de savoir jusqu'où est ce que
qu'on est dans le luxe ou pas le bus est
une question intéressante alors moi j'ai
raison
ensuite je vous rappelle que les
énergies renouvelables
il est deux principales dans bond c'est
la production de chaleur donc on n'est
pas du tout dans l'électricité
intermittente et c'est de l'énergie qui
t'a fait c'est au calme puisque c'est
d'hydroélectricité là dedans vous avez
là la moitié qui est produit par du fil
de l'eau et la moitié des produits dans
des barrages dernier donc l'idée que les
énergies renouvelables sont
intermittents donc sain qui en ce moment
font la une des journaux
oui les énergies renouvelables tous
confondus dont les abonnements sans
paroles portent aucun le vin ambroise
par les photographes les étages
renouvelable par bong présente
énormément de caractéristiques communes
avec le nucléaire c'est très
capitalistique
donc on en revient au même problème à
lui qu'on sent taux d'actualisation vous
faites rien vous faites les 3% du vix a
qu'une subvention domino
importante et déjà parlé de ton plus
sérieux vous avez et je vais refaire la
même réponse il faut faire une
combinaison en fonction de la question
posée de renouvelables le nucléaire est
éventuellement capture de co2 les
colonels évidemment il peut faire de la
capture de co2 ils vont vendre chèrement
que ça va faire ça dérange pas si vous
étiez du sens et bien pendant six lycées
et finit par les anciennes et les
économies d'énergie mais dont il faut
bien comprendre je l' ai dit valeur sur
les voitures que les économies d'énergie
elles ont une dimension culturelle
culturel mais dont tous les ingénieurs
là je le dis avec force qu'ils
s'imaginent naïvement que les économies
d'énergie c'est juste une affaire de
technique ce four le doigt dans l'oeil
jusqu'au plexus
quand vous diviser par quatre la paille
les voitures c'est pas une affaire
c'est une affaire culturel quand vous /
de l'espace habitable d'une affaires
culturelles quand vous dites que ça va
coûter la peau des fesses et aller en
avion voir sa vieille lambert qui chez
paou sculpture l accord donc les
économies d'énergie c'est pas technique
mais pas technique c'est technique au
culturel ou économique
or ça n'est pas technique il en est donc
passé à la question suivante on se voir
et c'est tout vous savez vraiment
prochain prime à rabat
il ya un tri entre temps il est chaud
froid ça je pense qu'il est bon les
journées alors parce que si les choses
risquent de refroidir son effroi dans
nos échanges européens je suis un
passionné de mobilité électrique
d'énergies renouvelables parce que
j'essaye de jeu pour toute question vous
venez d'évoquer en fait ça trotte dans
ma tête je les lis énormément en fait
deux choses là dessus parce que je
retiens de ce soir en fait c'est quelque
part on a trop d'énergie trop peu
d'énergie pendant peu pour se permettre
encore de la croissance mais on en a
encore trop que pour pouvoir sauver la
planète sur le nombre de membres a donné
tout ça c'est sexy c'est très
intéressant quand je pense que des gens
ont besoin de perspectives entre
guillemets réjouissante où il pourrait
trouver à leur échelle à leur niveau en
fait un levier d'action
c'est clair que si on trouve là le
problème dans sa globalité
ça laisse peu d'espoir les petits partis
donc c'est vrai que moi j'ai essayé un
nom les chaînes afin de voir comment je
pouvais avoir moins d'impact que j'ai
aucune prétention rester voyage
et par plaisir aussi enfin je roule en
voiture électrique si les scooters
électriques j'ai produit mon ampli cité
de son histoire
j'ai cette chance là je sais de prendre
les transports en commun quand c'est
plus efficace je prends une voiture qui
pollue quand je pense que je peux pas
faire autrement
moi ce qui m'a surtout choqué en fait
les gens bien sur la mobilité qui est un
thème qui m'appartiennent martin
particulièrement j'ai bien compris votre
position par rapport au temps que vous
énergies renouvelables qui sont
insignifiants de nucléaire qui est un
conte à mal par les mènerait au la tra
signifiante
mais on a en tout cas sont pas
insignifiants mettre en place en 2000 ce
mondial allons jusqu'au bout de
naissance
donc en fait voilà moi je pense quand on
y verra par exemple sur le
photovoltaïque ou en installant la
capacité de plusieurs centrales
nucléaires par an en terme de puissance
installée et ce qui est pour moi loin
d'être insignifiant quand on parle de
cycle de dix à vingt attendre installer
du nouveau nucléaire
le nucléaire il est mort parce que le
photovoltaïque a déjà beaucoup plus vite
que lui laissant d'abord vous effacez
c'est un peu une réflexion moi je
voudrais avoir des perspectives
positives faites alors que le consensus
pense que je partage tout
si on en reste là
fasse tirer une balle dans la tête dans
le boa loin et dans mon fils chiffres et
110 km/h mais commencer par une
réflexion pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
commencé par faire des choses qui
étaient insignifiantes
parce que ces mesures ont été portés par
des militants qui souvent des passages
remarqués souvent avec une lecture rares
économique de la société parce que
l'économie cette poignant le pognon
scellé sa capitaliste donc on veut pas
parler comment donc au lieu de faire de
calculs de dimensionnement un tout bon
ingénieur au lieu de faire des calculs
de retour sur investissement comme tout
manager terreur au lieu de faire de
quelques élus potentiels et ordre de
grandeur comme tout bon ingénieur où
poussent des idées romantiques des donc
le photovoltaïque c'est une idée
romantique d'antinucléaires alors ils
ont droit denis clerc aucun problème ils
ont droit d'être en arctique aucun
préalable inclus là où le bât blesse
c'est que la puissance publique
en face disposent normalement une armée
de fonctionnaires à criel loire un peu
faire plus confiance pour leur demander
de faire des calculs d'ordre de grandeur
une évaluation des connaissances
techniques disponibles et voir si la
revendication de machin truc il faut la
prendre en état ou pas et là le gros
problème reina l'essentiel les
démocraties occidentales
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a rompu
aujourd'hui la relation entre le monde
politique et les experts n'est pas une
relation de confiance aux relations des
certes d'accord pour des tas de raisons
sur lesquelles on pourrait discuter à
l'envi je rappelle qu'en france la
constituante qui avaient tous les bons
scientifiques de l'époque tous
maintenant c'est d'avoir un scientifique
à l'assemblée nationale chéneaux et tous
les présidents d'europe sont les avocats
quel est donc le don qu'il ya un la
décision prise qui remonte alors on
commence par pousser lui destine ralenti
on prend la destine comme à l'été
romantique il s'avère qu'à une marche
noire enfin vous exactement la
possibilité qu'elles marchent pas très
exactement ce qui s'est passé avec
vous pouvez dire déjà fait dix ans qu'on
dit c'est quand il s'arrêtera pas et
aujourd'hui c'est pas parce que la
puissance installée est significatif que
la production est significative parce
que le facteur de charge des décès huit
fois vainqueur centrales à charbon une
centrale nucléaire que l'investissement
faut le renouveler tous les 2 ou 3 2 ou
3 fois sur la durée de vie on s'embrasse
et que tant que c'est tout petit ça
roulera de perturbation dans leurs dents
plutôt le jour où ça sera très gros aura
une externalité bajaur en réseau qui
devra prendre à sa charge quelque chose
qui vous transporte de les réciter
fatale en électricité disponible qu'en
train doit avancer et juste revenu en
scène la révolution c'est à dire parce
que simplement je trouve qu'en belgique
il ya cinq ans il n'y avait pas
quasiment pas de volonté de cette
manette wii mais ça reste un loisir dans
cinq ans qu'aujourd'hui je fabrique ses
messages et de matériel clavier je
produis 500 la consommation est au
taquet dj dont presque toutes ces années
de tic et c'est assez anecdotique s'est
noyé dans les variations du reste des
échanges aux frontières croissance
négative
moi je dois en problème dans 50 % par
contre je veux pas de solution
révolution énergétique d'empathie fils
explique ronnie et finira sans doute ce
qui m'intéresse chez lui c'est qu'il a
réussi avant trois cent mille euros de
prestations à la région nord pas de
calais
ce que j'ai lu de la révolution et
d'angel où ils accueillent habillé d'un
pull bear dollar à 150 en avance nous
c'était bien pour l'embellir
pour finir sur la question des
renouvelables
toutes les monoplaces ne soit pas égal
les renault d'hakim eu des poussées
l'écran dire en dehors sourit
renouvelables électriques parce que tu
es poussé par les antinucléaires c'est
comme ça qu'il veut dire j'ai participé
à suffisamment d'exercice dit débat
public dans nos pays pour savoir que
c'est ça la figuration de débats reconnu
que les gens poussent des poêles à bois
qui en france sera l'autre plus
intelligent au lieu que poussent des
éoliennes et les panneaux
photovoltaïques qui en france d'un
strictement donc on revient à ce que je
disais tout à l'heure
problème sérieux m'étonne un peu solide
et solutions qui dépendent du contexte
dans lequel l'état est dans la question
en amérique le renouvelable je pense non
j'en ai envie d'une bonne optique le
soutient en fait non c'est très
différent
le renouvelable dakar de dollars qui
sont vachement bien dans certains
contextes qu'on a des événements
organisés c'est parfait très bien très
bonne idée
qu'on aille bien du solaire à
concentration dans sa très bonne idée
excellent j'aurais préféré un milliard
de fois que mes impôts servent à sable
de la finance et du lait en france un
milliard de fois donc je suis pas du
tout content les renouvelables
je suis content lui de lecture renault
l'optique de ça c'est bien ça c'est pas
là parce que c'est grâce à un mix type
de solutions non un objectif de résultat
c'est un objectif de résultat dans un
contexte d'optimisation sous contrainte
que vous connaissez par coeur d'un bond
des artilleurs tout une optimisation
soutien social économique parole c'est
sympa une autre question
je suis désolé
le maire donc là donc tout d'abord merci
beaucoup pour cette langue est juste moi
je suis analyste 100 marches électricité
chez ge et d'actuels et comment marche
le renouvelable j'ai envie de fin juste
de donner quelques chiffres justement ce
que vous dites
se pensant winston éolien et et pas des
types de potentiel pour [ __ ] ma taille
donc juste quelques chiffres présentent
avec vraiment la technologie actuelle
qui est construite en 2000 tous donc qui
était consciente l'année dernière pour
le photovoltaïque juste une étude de
potentiel
si on recouvre 30 % des surfaces badji
en france de panneaux photovoltaïques et
je fais le fait de devenir hostile et 11
ans ça fait 500 térawattheures c'est à
dire toutes les clarifications à saint
tropez au vent voilà donc comme ça
c'était juste un petit détail autrement
que par des subventions ruine est fort
le alors que l'éolien la subvention
c'est pendant dix ans 80 mégawatts heure
et ensuite c'est moins la saint yves
ferrasse mort et ces remaniements de
8,58 quand les chiites ont comparé deux
produits qui sont pas plus par
appartements sert de rien
vous avez de manière propre de comparer
l'éolien à autre chose l'éolien defourny
d'électricité par an de vous les faire
avancer à fin mai quand le vent souffle
donc en économie de manière propre de
traiter ça ou bien rudy qui en
dispositifs de bakker et quand le vent
souffle j'ai dit le combustible dans mon
dispositif de backup et a souvent vous
devez comparer le coût de l'éolien
complet avec les coûts du combustible
élite est d'accord si vous avez du
chardon et qu'en plus vous avez
dt co2 à rien très bien nous mettre des
éoliennes si vous avez du nucléaire avec
un taux marginal de combustible qui est
égal à zéro
tu désolé c'est 80 mégawatts heure
dépensé en pure perte et manager joe des
gains ensuite vous avez une deuxième
manière propre de comparer c'est de dire
je calcule le coût du dispositif le
transforme l'électricité via rail par le
vent souffle en électricité que
j'utilise quand j'ai besoin de faire
avancer un frein ou faire fonctionner le
monde alors deviner nos deux bobines
d'accord
hélas comment vous devez expliciter ce
coût ce qui est déjà un fait absolument
en effet c'est magic réseau quelques
bars qui va s'occuper du machin vous
êtes traders électrique qui savait très
bien de temps en temps dans nord de
l'allemagne
il ya des prix d'électricité négatif
c'est à dire qu'il ya tellement
d'électricité éolienne aux personnes de
ces préfère que bell et jean effets
négatifs du prix dégressifs
ils étaient six métiers d'ailleurs le
jeu vous paie 200 euros du
mégawattheures que vous prenez mon
électricité pour le soja concerne trois
grands pôles hilary swank donc c'est
bien la preuve que vous avez une
externalité quelque part dans certaines
économies malveillantes
non disons qu'elle céderait ses brevets
juste à 5 % d'électricité éolienne la
panne juste un an moment on est bien
plus que ça 35 des rabatteurs en 2011
sur attention par l'ampleur et aux lieux
ils n'ont plus d'électricité issue de la
biomasse y en eut il ya plus de 50 des
ravageurs de production éolienne
en 2002 juin 2011 ou en 2012 c'est
certain imminent soit pour faire monter
des chandelles et les départs on va
quand même revenir dans le disque est
intéressant ce débat ait pas eu de match
entre son sens à ce que l'énergie c'est
bien dire littérature scientifique
alors parfois je n'ai pas encore de la
mémoire des gens que le chiffre que je
m'en serais pas ici
c'est ce qu'un tel essor vous savez
comme la fin de la question que vous
venez juste puisque j'ai découpé
non je voulais comparer les coûts ça je
suis d'accord si on veut dire qu'il va
faire son 300 devenir si on en fait 25%
comme comme comme les singles ou 30%
comme le danemark
on n'a pas besoin de systèmes de back
est donc on va vendre ses parts dont dix
ont remporté les marques installées
renseignez-vous les capacités installées
en espagne ou garder le double de celle
installée en éolien aujourd'hui quand
l'espagne comme un kilowattheure
d'éolien l entremise de gare les
émissions de co2 espagnol s'est replié
par 316 40 ans d usure et 6 0
l'économie espagnole est la même
aujourd'hui 165 d'accord la met donc un
mineur ont commencé par appeler les
choses comme évident même nom avant tout
et c'est dans ce que je vous raconte moi
aussi c'est mon rôle
le flegme si l'évolution des capacités
installées
l'évolution est sûr c'est que gdf suez
du silence les climato-sceptiques aux
étrangers les états unis donc le juste
pour finir là-dessus
renseignez-vous sur l'esthétisme
capacité installée vous verrez qu'en
espagne et une capacité en mai chez sia
je perdais tout je suis hantée maynard
um spéculer sur les marchés où traînait
sur les marchés c'est pas un truc de
capacités installées sur 30 ans je pense
qu'on a compris dès que je te propose ce
qu'il fait
gdf suez perd être capable via les
places sur le monde en tout temps
christian bourquin national union à
copenhague en 2009 tous les gaziers sont
succédé à la tribune pour expliquer que
l'éolien
génial guerre mondiale c'est tellement
difficile pourrait être motors est un
peu de nécessité
on les deux dernières questions dont
mossoul est ensuite la parole et puis
après il ya un bris fait continuer à
discuter mais donc de n'être question
explosive et je vais changer un petit
peu diffusés d'obliger pardon ça va ça
tombe bien on trouve à l'idée
d'instaurer dans la sûreté nucléaire
j'ai connu tous vous parler de ça c'est
une question d'ordre philosophique et
c'est à dire d'après ce que vous
expliquiez ce que je crois comprendre de
la situation bien aussi un aspect très
forte et l harmonisation au niveau
global de l'opération sur mon site
fonctionne et si des gens ne font pas
que le vin ne suivent pas le mouvement
donc la question allait elle c'est
simple je crois que la nature humaine
n'est pas très humaniste on va dire ça
comme ça donc je vais peut-être un peu
fataliste mais je ne prends pas de
paiement en l'avenir en ce sens qu'il
imagine assez mal comment certains ne
vont pas profiter de la situation c'est
à dire les efforts des autres pour
mettre entre guillemets réduit à néant
parce que d'autres vont choisir de faire
exactement le contraire pour s'enrichir
je voulais savoir comment wiltord il ya
des affaires depuis dix ans parce que je
moi je
j'ai pas d'aller sur est-ce qu'on est
tous foutu tout est ce que va s'en
sortir
j'ai envie de vous dire on est un peu
sur le pont de singe au pied du lit
des fois ça se termine bien mais parce
qu'ils terminent mal et dans les
éléments alors la première chose que je
pense c'est que l'europe est dos au mur
nous je pense qu'on a un intérêt de
court terme évident a commencé à
décarbonés l'économie aussi vite que
possible
si on fait pas ça on verra l'arrivée des
populismes et on verra t on pour
renvoyer à la question de tout à l'heure
moi je ne suis pas prêt à faire plaisir
en dehors de panneaux photovoltaïques si
ça me fait prendre trois ans dans la
couche contre la montre pour empêcher le
retour des dictateurs nord il ya un
homme célèbre en france et de marseille
ne touchent pas si l'autre est décédé
qui avait écrit en 2004 le big tap que
de ne pas mettre en place une taxe
carbone
c'était l'assurance de la dictature
encore une fois à tokyo lente mais qui
résume exactement ce que je vous ai
raconté
dix autres avant le départ les forces de
frottement l'âme il faut donc
donc je pense que l'europe un intérêt
objectif puisque pétrole et gaz sont
déjà en train de baisser à ceux dé
carbonée aussi vite que possible
l'europe par ailleurs a fait une
construction politique unique au monde
unique au monde qui est que les états à
appliquer partie de leur souveraineté
sur un certain nombre de sujets dont des
mesures concernant la réglementation des
armes
quand lord a commencé par faire milan
aux conneries à mon avis qui est la
libéralisation des marchés l'électricité
dans rails parce que quand vous pilotez
des infrastructures à 50 ans voulait bt
pas entre les mains de gens chez qui la
stratégie de montée en question sans
parler de ce consultant parce que le
temps avec ces gens là se croisent à
partir du moment où vous avez des gens
qui raisonnent à travers leurs codes et
pas des autres jeunes ils doivent
assurer quelque chose qui est vital pour
la collectivité pendant cinquante ans
vous faites pas ça mais il n'empêche
qu'on a quand même fait
ni moment marque qui est qu'on a la
possibilité d'harmoniser les choses
toutes faites et si l'europe veut bien
prendre conscience du fait que vous dire
après comment on peut y arriver que les
déjà dos au mur on a intérêt à pousser
on reste quand même la première ronde
économiquement viable pour lui et je
pense que si l'europe fait ça à marche
accélérée
on est aussi des bas niveaux mimétique
puisque c'est comme ça qu'un élève deux
enfants et je suis pas complètement
désespéré à l'idée que l'on peut pas
approuver des casques ans dans un
terrain de dialogue avec les grands
émergents comme plus quelques états unis
le reste qui ont déjà les mêmes
problèmes des chinois et je pourrais
même claude espace mistral etc
les brésiliens ont un peu moins mais
voilà qu'on peut discuter avec tous ces
gens là question comment est ce que
l'europe peut réaliser qu'elle est dos
au mur et là je vais vous faire une
lecture en réussite et mon docteur
favorise pas encore citer jusqu'à marché
automobile en démocratie les décisions
ne se prennent pas sur la base de la
réforme et sur la base des rapports de
force c'est la règle du jeu faut savoir
plus le monde ils tiraient finalement
mondial je sais pas c'est pas dit qu'on
est comme un certain dan et de pacifier
les décisions crois pas que l'angleterre
est restée une démocratie pendant la
dernière guerre je ne sais pas quelle
est la capacité des démocraties où à
churchill est derrière la planche
je sais pas
donc juste ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'il faut s'appuyer sur des gens qui
sont susceptibles de provoquer le droit
par de fortes c'est qu'ils les gens qui
sont susceptibles de provoquer le mans
avant nos forces c'est tous les acteurs
économiques qui pensent qu'ils ont
personnellement à gagner si on met des
contraintes sur le pneu
c'est comme ça que ça marche c'est à
dire le premier débat sur l'énergie
auquel j'ai participé enfants c'était en
2003 donc depuis 2003 je fréquente après
souvent et quand même de temps en temps
des gens du monde politique et de la
haute des clauses structure donc je
crois bien comment ça marche
il faut s'appuyer sur les jeunes seront
les gagnants potentiels de la faire pour
faire changer les récuser c'est comme ça
que ça marche le centre ou zidane
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'on s'appuie
sont les perdants potentiels dans la
sphère il ya un certain nombre de trucs
qui vu de votre fenêtre ce soir par as
utile pour la collectivité qui n'arrive
pas eh bien vous faire exactement la
même chose dans l'autre sens alors qui
sont les gagnants potentiels de la faire
une large fraction d'activité
construction parce que si vous devez
refaire les livres en faire les épaules
horaires etc
on va faire les infrastructures de
transport ça c'est du bdp avant que
finir une partie des électriciens à tous
une large plaie tous les gens qui
fabriquent des petites voitures sont des
gagnants potentiels de la faire je vous
rappelle que les taxes élevées sur les
câbles en droit sauver les constructeurs
automobiles en 2008 et en 2009 au moment
où general motors a fait faillite des
constructeurs européens ils ont un peu
souffert beaucoup moins parce que ça
faisait tellement longtemps qu'on avait
des moteurs de consommer moins et des
taxes non proportionnels aux prix sur
les carburants consommés que nous on est
beaucoup plus facilement passer
à travers laquelle va repose états unis
il en est carburant moins taxé et non
sans passer de manière extrêmement grave
les ventes de pick-up je suis d'être 50
ans je vais pas utiliser pour autant de
force que j'aime je pensais que j'arrive
à chaque fois encore de l'évolution de
ma part une fois l'énergie aie a
précisément ce qu'ils ont longtemps et
donc finir là-dessus donc je pense que
l'une des bonnes actions
en tout cas moi c'est une de celles que
j'essaye et poussé c'est de faire un
lobby croissant oph rachat de tous les
gens qui ont un intérêt économique à
s'occuper sérieusement de première et ça
n'explique pas m'étendre c'est pas pour
autant qu'ils occupent la place donc le
l'idée s'est agrégée un nombre croissant
de gens qui pensent qu'une vision
intérêts pour avoir voix au chapitre
parce qu'encore une fois tant dans un
média du gard outillage à mes gars vous
recevez des communiqués de presse et des
machins pouvoir pour être entendue que
auprès des pouvoirs publics
vous êtes dans une situation dans
laquelle gérer des rapports de force
beaucoup plus que vous ne gérez de
l'information dit raisonnable la
participante etc cette notion est donc
donc l'action elle passe par là tout
simplement je trouve ici le mans
l'occasion de lever parce que maintenant
tirer une conclusion qui ne sont pas
pertinentes
c'est dans un projet
quel on met une énergie en commun en vue
d'un expliquant que 18 à l'heure d'aller
dans quelque chose qui est plus positif
oui donc il faut se mettre autour natale
je fais conclusions des records d'avoir
un cric
wood en tout cas il ya un moment du
débat est important
la démocratie c'est ça et je pense qu'on
a besoin de démocratie le pire moment de
décider de dire oui à des choses serait
d'en guérir elle est en péril
la finale est pour ça que c'est
important que le débat se pressent pour
décider et en tout cas là dedans on va
les parents de vie justement continuer
le débat
partagez et profitez alors je vous
rappelle rendez vous ici dans deux
semaines sur un autre débat ou
technologiques
celle ci
le prochain smic asmar ce sont les mots
que le maire qui persistent sur les
pédales fille merci à tous merci jean
marc jancovici